>> Welcome to Google I/O 2018.
We're happy you joined us to
celebrate platform improvements
at Google.  Right now you
checked into registration to see
your badge.
It must be visibly warn at all
times
and you'll need it to enter the
I/O shuttles and enter the
end-of-day activities one and
two
Make sure to visit Google.
com/I/O.
Or download the Google app for
the
most up-to-date information
Chat with any staff member
wearing a yellow badge.
Sessions will take place in the
aphitheater as well as the eight
stages throughout the venue.  If
you haven't already reserve a
seat
for your favorite session on the
app.  If you miss a session,
don't worry recordings will be
available shortly after they
end.
Be sure to visit the codelabs
codelabs Google staff will be
online for helpful advice and
provide direction if you need
support
Make some time to visit the
office hours to meet one-on-one
with Googlers and ask your
questions and get feedback on
your projects.  If you're
looking to network with Googlers
and fellow developers, join one
of the several meetups hosted in
the lounge
Finally visit the sandbox domes
where you can explore, learn,
and play
with the latest demos, physical
installations and more.  After
sessions are done for the day,
stick around for foods, drinks,
music and fun and be prepared
for some surprises along the
way.  We would like to take this
opportunity to remind you that
we are  dedicating to providing
an inclusive event experience
for everyone, and that by
attending Google I/O you agree
to our code of conduct posted
throughout the venue
Your opinion is valuable to us.
After the event, look out for a
feedback form to share your
experience.  Thanks for
attending and have a
wonderful time exploring Google
I/O.
(music)
>> At this time, please
find your seat.  Our session
will begin soon.
(music)
>> Come on up, guys.
(Applause)
>> Hello everyone.
Good morning and welcome to
fragment in an architecture
components world.  In the case
of architecture components a lot
of people have been asking
questions, like how do all of
these things fit together.
Hopefully we'll able to answer
some of those questions today.
First, just a little bit of
history.
The Fragment APIs go back to
2010 is when they were first
initially written
and 2011 when there was a little
more
widespread availability.  At the
very beginning everybody just
started with the activity when
you were writing a Android app.
The the main method with the
lifecycle.  The entry point to
the application.  The launcher
launches activity, you
get the create, start, resume,
et cetera, events that you all
know and love
It will create views for
you, it creates the window,
gives you a place to view your
view hierarchy where you do most
of the UI work.  It binds the
consent from the app state, or
at least this is where people
tended to do it.  Keep in mind
this was fairly early in the
Android public lifecycle.
Everybody had a habit of piling
everything into one activity
because apps were a lot more
simple than they are today
Of course, you listen to UI
events and update that app state
from there as well.  So there
are so many incoming events, it
really kind of became this
plumbing exercise to try to
break it up yourself,
and so people ended up with
these very
monolithic activities.  And
Android tablets became a thing,
and we thought how do you make a
tablet UI?  You take one phone
UI, you take another phone UI
and smack them together and you
have a tablet UI, right.  What
could go wrong?
So we needed to answer the
question of how to stick two
phone UIs together and make sure
it still works on a phone.  And
fragments were kind of our
answer to this question.
So as an example here, this
approach actually worked pretty
well for some applications.
Gmail is a great example.  If
you take a look you have the
list of conversations to your
current conversation that you're
taking a look at, and there is
not a whole lot of difference
here between the phone version
that you drill into versus
something that you can show side
by side
in a two  two-pane UI.
fragments were allowed to split
up the two UI classes.  We were
seeing the pain developers were
feeling and activity classes
were getting really big and hard
to  manage, so we wanted to see,
could we allow for you to
decouple some of the various
things that your activity
classes are doing to sort of
relieve a little bit of that
pressure.
So that means that anything a
fragment can do, or anything an
activity can do, a fragment had
to be able to do too, and that
guided a whole lot of the API
design from the beginning, so
that meant that you needed to
have  lifecycle events, and that
meant that you needed to be able
to manage a view hierarchy
It meant that you needed to be
able to deal with a saved
instance state, so
packaging everything up into a
bundle or parcellables so if
your application got killed in
the background you could restore
from that in a clean way.  And
other things as well like
nonconfiguration instance object
passing, and that's always kind
of a
a mouthful but it allows you to
pass
across that doesn't kill the
idea
If you were navigating between a
single opportunity we want to
make sure you preserve the same
backstack activity from just
calling activity from screen to
screen
So, along the way we asked the
question, can we fix some other
APIs that were really kind of a
pain in the
neck in Android to use?
Unretained, nonconfiguration
instance, again kind of a
mouthful.  This had some
problems because you only got
one object that you could pass
from activity instance to
activity instance
We didn't give you any easy
or standardized way to multiplex
different objects together so
for example if you were
composing multiple libraries, we
didn't give you a whole lot of
help.  This was all boilerplate
that you had to write yourself.
Activityshowdialogue.  Anybody
remember this?  A few people.
Okay.
>> IAN LAKE: Please forget
it immediately.
>> ADAM POWELL: Yeah,
please forget it.  This was
essentially a way to get the
activity to do something that we
knew was missing and kind of a
pain in the neck.  In allowed
you to make the activity on
the other side after a
configuration change, the new
instance of your activity reshow
what is semantically the same
dialogue.
We also had this thing,
local activity manager, tab
host, does anybody remember this
one?  Wow!  That is a lot more
hands than I thought I would
see.
So some of you might
remember this from say the
example of the original dialer
and contacts app back in kind of
the Android 2.0 days.  And as
you've swopped between tabs,
between the normal number pad
and your contact list or call
log, et cetera, those were
actually separate activities
showing within a smaller window
within an activity, this idea of
nesting activities was something
that we started offering very
early.  It had a lot of other
issues though.  Activities made
a whole lot of promises that
local activity manager had a lot
of trouble trying to uphold so
we tried to tighten that
interface a little better for
something composable like
fragments that would be able to
do the same thing but with a
little more  expected behavior.
>> IAN LAKE: Right, so
this whole idea of being able to
break up your activity and make
it into kind of composable
pieces, you know, we have
this giant monolith of activity
and other methods of factoring
it out into
different piece, but for
fragments our approach was to
move the loosely associated
code, the view and all of the
state around that view, into a
separate fragment.
And you basically just keep
doing this until you've kind of
segmented out your activity into
something that looks slightly
more reasonable, right.  You may
have a couple of fragments in
here that kind of have their own
specific requirements and their
own specific UI, and your
activity just becomes more of a
shell for this.
But soon after we started
getting
into this and when it came up to
around Jelly Bean, people were
like but this isn't enough.
What if one of my fragments has
a view pager in it that also has
fragments as each one of its
pages, so we get into this, all
right, well now let's break up
the fragments into smaller
piece, and so of course, you
know, the only way if fragments
aren't enough, then you just
add more fragments, in this case
child fragments became a  thing.
And so now each one of
these fragments could then be
broken up into smaller pieces,
so this led us to kind
of again kind of decouple things
and we built a lot of code
around trying to
make this nested state work
really well.
Two varying levels of degree of
success, but it's gotten a lot
better over time.
So, with these things in mind,
every one of those fragments,
whether
it's a small thing just managing
a view
or if it's a retained instance
fragment, every single one of
these fragments give you
lifecycle hooks, every single
one of them has back stack
management associated with them,
every single one of them has a
retained object that it can do
across configuration changes,
and all of them are stored
statefuly in your fragment
manager.
That means that the existence of
that fragment is actually part
of the state
of your app, so when your app
dies and
comes back, that existence in
the Fragment Manager is actually
a really important part, at
least from fragments
perspective, that we're going to
do on your behalf, and of
course, they all have their own
ability to have a view subtree
so that piece of your UI that
they manage themselves.
And of course, we also allow
things like fragments being
inflatable and put
right into your XML files and be
able to reuse them across
multiple layout, and again this
is also kind of hooking into
these same processes, but the
biggest
issue we found is that all these
fragments do all of these things
at once whether you want them to
or not.  And most of the time
you're only actually using one
or two of these things and not
the full 16 things that
fragments do that you get as
kind of a bundle of deal.
So that means that some of these
things like the stateful
restoration means you have a lot
of patterns that look like this
where you have to make
sure that the
Fragment Manager is in the right
state.  In this case we're
actually checking, there no
saved instance state?
Ie, are we in a fresh run of
this activity, and oh, now I
need to add my fragments to my
layout.  If you've ever gotten
this approach, where you have
one fragment over another one,
yeah that is this kind of
stateful
restoration actually doing
something
that was a useful bit but at the
same  point, like maybe not
exactly what you were expecting
or something that you even
wanted in some cases.  But for
fragment, you kind of got all
of them together in a package
deal.
But last year, we kind of took a
more holistic approach
holistic approach on how we do
API, and so all of the
architecture components have
really tried to focus in on
doing one thing well rather than
being kind of
the kitchen sink kind of
approach.
So for example, lifecycle
observers, the ability to have
lifecycle
and that unresume, unstart as
kind of a
piece that is completely
independent from other things,
something you can register just
if you care about  lifecycle.
Similarly, for view model,
we created a new  primitive, a
new object specifically for that
kind of retained instance state
across configuration changes,
and of course this year, just
yesterday, we announced a new
navigation
architecture component, kind of
working at the much higher level
architecture on how you build
your UI and put these things
together and really trying to
tackle just these specific
problems of how do you move from
one screen to the next screen.
All of these things were
really
kind of focused on doing one
thing well, and we're trying to
bring a lot of that to
fragments, but that means that,
you know, we kind of have a lot
of legacy to go along with them.
>> ADAM POWELL: That's
right.  So part of this is that
fragments were really designed
around this idea of very
lose
about loose dependencies and
activities that go around behind
them.  Question for the
audience, how many know the
question, does a child uncreate
method run before or after the
parents uncreate method?  How
many of you are confident you
know the answer?  Not a whole
lot.
How many of you --
>> IAN LAKE: No idea? Is
that an option?
>> ADAM POWELL: How many
of you thought you knew the
answer before I asked the
question and then you started
questioning yourself?  Yeah.
Okay.  I'll fully admit that
sometimes I have to doublecheck
this as well because the
answer really kind of of on
whether the parent is a activity
or fragment.
Android.app fragments or support
fragments?  The answer is
different all the time.  We
changed this around.  If you
were trying to design a
fragment that  worked across all
versions of Android dealing with
the fragment, you had to deal
with these rules changing under
you a bit.  You couldn't count
on anything.
So one of the things we allowed
for lifecycle  observers is that
we really wanted to give a very
strict ordering of the
callbacks.  You have a strict
last in and first out callback
ordering for all lifecycle
observers in any given
lifecycle.  This is important
because it means you can set up
dependencies between lifecycle
observers and use lifecycle
observers as the implementation
details of a particular activity
instance or fragment instance as
the case may be.
You can make sure to maintain
guarantees between certain
lifecycle events so that any
other lifecycle observers or
other libraries that you may be
using can take advantage of
those
guarantees that you've
configured.
Lifecycle observers are created
by you.  We don't try to
recreate them via reflection,
which means that you can use
any sort of creation pattern
that you may find useful within
your app.
So this seems like a really
small thing, but it was a big
piece of feedback that we got
with fragments.  The implication
of that though is that
you no longer get  stateful
restoration by the system.  In
some cases this is exactly what
you want.  You want to make sure
that you have a single control
flow path as you're configuring
what your lifecycle observers.
You don't want to be checking,
hey, is my instance state going
to bring this back for me?
I don't want to end up with two
of these things and so on and so
forth.
>> IAN LAKE: Right. One
of the really common patterns we
saw a lot of app developers
using is a headless fragment, a
fragment without a UI.
That was used basically only to
receive on start, on stop
lifecycle
events and so for a lot of these
kind of approach, lifecycle
observers are going to give you
the same kind of API service
but with a lot smaller kind of
API that you don't actually need
all of the things of fragment.
So what does this actually
look like?
You might have just a simple
lifecycle observer that does
analytics calls and your
analytics library might want
on-start, on-stop of a
particular lifecycle.
So the thing here is that this
is an independent piece from
fragments,
from activities.  That has a
couple of super important things
in that one, you can test it
independently, you don't have to
spin off the whole world just to
test this piece.  You can test
it in isolation.
Also, because you can
create this observer, you can
use whatever methods
you want if you want to use a
dependency injection kind of
model and inject in your
dependencies, like that is
really easy to do in this model
rather than trying to do it in
the scope of an activity or
fragment or doing that kind of
thing.
So this gives you a lot more
power
to kind of split out this into a
composable piece, so if you're
building
a library, you can just use this
same
lifecycle observer across all of
your fragments or all of your
activities and not have to
duplicate that data or worry
about, like okay, what state is
my instance state in.  You can
always say, add the observer,
and we're done.  There is no
more work you need to do here,
so this offers a lot simpler
alternative for this specific
use case.
>> ADAM POWELL: Okay.
We've got some glowing  slides
to get through.  Okay.
So re retained instance
fragments were designed to
outlive an activity.  These were
basically just a setter on a
fragment to say, hey, retain my
instance state across
configuration changes.
So it's a pretty useful thing
because it meant that you could
safe handles to expensive data
or expensive operations.  If you
start some sort of query that
might take a bit to complete,
you don't want to restart
because something rotated the
screen or something got resized.
It meant that you could
reconnect to these same
operations after that
configuration change, but really
please don't do UI during this.
This was another one of those
kind of  headache pain points
sort of things, fragments do
everything all at once, but
these were two things that just
really did not taste great
together.  The reasoning for
this is, of course, that views
hold on to the context that
created them.  Well, what
context do you use to create
views most of the time?  It ends
up being the activity.  You
don't want to hold on to a
reference after an old activity
after a configuration change and
end up using the same views.
Technically it's possible
to do this right and drop all of
your references on destroy view,
recreate the
view after you come around the
other side, but this was way too
difficult to get right all the
time, just because  references
to the views end up leaking out
and getting everywhere no matter
what you try to do, so this was
something that was really just
kind of a foot gun waiting to
hurt people.
>> IAN LAKE: But of course
in the architecture component
world, there is a different
solution for this retained
instance pattern, and that comes
in the
model of
ViewModels, and this is a new
class, and to be honest it
doesn't really do a whole lot.
It's how to connects to the
overall system.  Instead of
being, again, part of the
Fragment APIs, this is a more
general purpose thing, something
that you can attach to any
activity or any fragment
or any Viewmodel store owner if
you build in your own framework.
The main thing that's
different
here, just kind of like the
lifecycle
observers, is that we are not
the owner of creating those
object, so by default we provide
a factory that just creates a
new instance or creates a new
instance and attaches your
application context to
it, but the same point, this is
a super powerful hook for again
kind of adding in those extra
dependencies, so if you're using
dependency injection, like again
you have kind of the hooks you
need to hook into the Viewmodel
creation
and pass them in as a
construction parameter, there
doesn't need to be a more
complicated structure than that.
So but you get into the
same problem of like, okay, well
how do I connect my UI?  And the
other piece of the puzzle here
is a different architecture
component
called  Live Data and Live Data
is all
about kind of a lifecycle aware
observer, so in this model, in
this
world, your  Viewmodel is the
one who is
storing the data, right, and
it's the LiveData that it has
that it can pass to the activity
or fragment as they get
created and recreated, and that
fragment
or activity can just observe the
LiveData that the ViewModel own,
and so this separates it out so
instead of being the ViewModel
that needs to hold on to a
reference to view, the activity
can then pull the information
out of the ViewModel.
So I think for a lot of use
cases, where you're using a
restained instance state
specifically to kind of store
this
expensive data and do that kind
of work,
ViewModels offer really good
alternative to retained instance
fragments, and so what's a a
super simple one look like?
Well, in this case we're going
to
use an Android  ViewModel so
here we get a reference to your
application, your application
context, so this is really
useful if you're doing things
like a service locater kind of
pattern, but the
important thing here is that the
ViewModel stores an instance of
a
LiveData in this case a LiveData
has a list of our fancy named
expensive data class.  Normally
you put this in line, but slides
are hard so here we're using it
and we're getting our data from
a room database, a simple RM
database.
But you can really get this
data from anywhere or set up
kind of the
correct lifecycle events here so
that
your  LiveData can kind of get
into the right state.  But that
means that your actual fragments
or activities don't need to know
where this data came from,
right.
Its encapsulated in the
ViewModel and again we're in the
same thing where we can now test
this ViewModel in isolation and
we don't need to create
activity, we don't need to
create fragments to get to this
same view model.  We can just
use them in isolation and make
sure that all of the work we
need here to get our expensive
data and make sure that it's in
the right state can
all be done kind of separate
from the
actual UI pieces of the
framework.
>> ADAM POWELL: All right. So
everybody's favorite topic when
it
comes to the Fragment API is
fragment
transactions because this is a
statement
that is said by pretty much no
one ever.
(laughter).
Fragment transactions are
asynchronous by default.  If you
call it it gets posted for later
and it will occur on kind of the
next handler post on the main
thread, or if another lifecycle
event is coming up we'll execute
the  pending transactions, bring
it to a consistent state before
we move to the next state.
Now, this actually has a few
benefits to it, believe it or
not, for as much as everybody
gets kind of frustrated about it
and the biggest
wasn't is there is no re-enter
ree fragment operation, if you
manipulate fragments within say
the on-create of another
fragment you don't start getting
into a state where you have a
half-initiallyized frackment
while you're waiting for bring
another fragment up to  speed.
This is a source of
countless bugs are and I think
it was earlier this week or last
week that we were helping
developers troubleshoot some
other
re-enterrant behavior bugs
coming from view callbacks, for
example.  This is the sort of
thing that can be really subtle.
The asynchronous things sidestep
all of it and that was kind of
convenient.
The drawbacks are, of course,
that the observed state at any
given point in time doesn't
actually reflect any of the
queued transactions, and so this
is a huge problem.  This
basically means that if one
piece of your code submits a
fragment transaction, another
piece of your code tries to read
something out of state that that
fragment would have set up for
you, whether that's another view
hierarchy that would have gotten
attached to a subhierarchy of
the UI, or whether it's just
some data about pending
operation for one of the
restained instance operations,
this
means you can't trust anything
about the current state of the
app.  It means you can have
various data races within the
main part of your application.
We've even seen people run into
layered parts on top of each
other because of this issue.
They were checking the fragment
manager to see what is my
current UI pane for example
that's currently there.  It said
oh, look nothing, I don't have
anything to do, let me make a
new
fragment transaction and sick
stick something there, but this
was already in flight.  This was
a pain in the neck and everybody
loved the commit-now API was
added because it lets you do
something immediately as long as
you promise not to do anything
with the current fragment
manager as part of that
transaction.
>> IAN LAKE: But we kind
of get to this point  where,
okay, now we have all of these
fragment transaction codes in
your app and very subtle changes
that
you may not pick up in a simple
CL are all of a sudden changing
the whole behavior of your app.
And we really took a look
at this and we said, well, like
should you really have to be
writing all of these fragment
transactions by hand?
Like, for so many of the use
cases we can do a little bit
better here.  We can do a lot
better here, especially for the
really common cases.
So we had built navigation, a
brand new architecture component
that's really kind of focused on
the  screen-to-screen
transitions between fragments or
other UI pieces because we
really wanted to make it work
well with fragments.  Fragments
are a really great way of
getting access to Livecycle
observers and view models and
also, you know,
being an owner of a view and
those are really kind of the
main pieces you need
when you're trying to build a
good Android app.
At the same point, we realize
there are a lot of things that
fragments do that we don't
really want you to have to
deal with yourself, so one of
the things with navigation that
we really focused
on was actually being able to
take ownership of the back stack
and make sure that the
navigation component can
actually handle that back stack
for you,
whether you're using fragments
or something else, the
ownership with that back stack
goes with navigation, and that
gives us a lot more flexibility
and a little more ability to be
a little more prescriptive and
opinionated on what is a good
thing to do and what is a not so
great thing to do and kind of
give you a lot of the same power
of fragment transactions without
actually having to touch one
with your bare hands.  Because
again, we're trying to make
things so that, you know, you
have all
of the power without necessarily
the headache and the problems
that run across some of the
things that Adam pointed out.
So we're going to be
talking in detail about
navigation tomorrow morning at
8:30.  I know you're all early
risers, but I wanted to give you
a little bit of a preview of
kind of how simple this could
be, so we actually offer a
helper method where if you want
to click a button and
do a full screen transition to
another
fragment, we have a create
navigate on click listener that
literally does just that.  All
you need to do is pass in the
IED of one of those destinations
that you've set up in
Navigation.
Now, this looks a little
bit magical, and so what is this
actually doing under the covers?
Well, really what it's doing is
using
this Navcontroler object.  And
one of the things that I find
super useful about Navigation is
you can find the Navcontroler
from any view or any fragment
that's been created by
Navigation, so here we're using
a column extension which makes
this a lot easier.
If you're in a Java land it's
just a static method, but here
we can find from any view, we
can just say find Navcontroler
and get an instance of the
Navcontroler and then just call
Navigate.  And this Navigate
call knows how to do
fragment transactions so our
Navcontroler in this case is set
up with
a fragment navigator, our own
class that knows all about the
correct behavior of doing
fragment transactions and how to
do all of that work for you so
that from your codes
perspective, you can just call
Navigate and we'll do the right
thing for you.
So obviously there is a lot
more
here, like if you want to pass
arguments, like you can do a
bundle approach and we also have
a lot more things around that
specific case that we'll be
talking about tomorrow as well,
as well as setting things like
separate animations and other
objects in here.
So you have a lot of the same
power, but you can also make it
really easy to use and move a
lot of the code that used to be
a fragment transaction that
you'd have to make really sure
that you got right into
something that Navigation can
understand and help with.
So Adam, we've talked about a
lot of things like why not
fragment, but this is kind of a
fragment talk, right?
>> ADAM POWELL: I think that's
why everyone is  here.
>> IAN LAKE: Yeah, so why
fragments?  It's 2018.
>> ADAM POWELL: It is 2018. So
what are fragments still good
for after we've sort of carved
off some of these extension
points?
To before we talk about
that, I think it's kind of more
than to go into a little bit of
the package layering involved in
the Android framework,
specifically  Android.widget
versus Android.app.  Now
Android.widget is really kind of
designed to hold the mechanism
for your UI.  That means that
this is all the stuff that shows
state to the user and things
that reports user interaction
events back to other higher
level portions of your app.
Really, that's it.  Everything
that's in the widget package is
really meant to only do these
two things, whereas  Android.app
where fragments live, activities
live, so on and so forth, that's
where your policy goes.  This is
what defines what state to bind
to widgets.  This is what
defines how you should respond
to those user interaction events
and how to issue changes to your
data model, anything kind of at
that layer or above, no matter
how you may factor it, this is
kind of how it breaks down.
So this also brings us to the
idea of inflatable components
which is something that comes up
quite a bit.  Since you can
inflate a fragment from a
layout, people found out really
quickly that you can use a
fragment to compose some of your
views together and create,
basically like a custom view but
with a fragment.
And really some of this
kind of comes in because people
start asking, you know, just if
this view had a  lifecycle I
could....something.  But really
you want to kind of use that as
a stopping point and just kind
of ask yourself, like what is it
about in particular view?
Remember, mechanism only, what
is it
about this particular view about
the lifecycle.
It should be only seeing or
publishing user action if the
user clicks or performs anything
themselves.  None of these need
lifecycle events to accomplish
that goal.  So you should watch
out and see if you need some
policy layer that sits above
that.
This is where fragments are
really useful because you can
compose them of higher-level
controls.  It means that they
can be self-sufficient, they
have their own lifecycle, they
know how to hook into
some of these things.  It means
that inflated attributes can
actually become fragment
arguments so you can make these
things super self-sufficient and
implement cross-cutting UI
policies that you don't have to
worry about in terms of like the
over arching top-level parent
context.  This ends up being
really useful for things like, I
mean even just something as
simple as ads, something where
you really do need to control
for a lifecycle about when a
user comes and goes, perform a
request out to the network to
fetch the don't that you're
going to show, but really you
don't want that code getting all
over throughout the rest of your
application logic.
Can you use this for other sorts
of like independent info cards,
things that are, again, fully
self-contained.  The parent
doesn't actually need to be
involved in any of the data
routing from your central
repository or whatever other
sort of model you're using under
the hood in order to get that on
screen
and get the user interacting
with it.
So one example of using the
fragment arguments for this is
on the screen here.  This is the
sort of thing we can probably
benefit from some extensions or
helpers, but overall it's not
too bad if you define a stylable
to go ahead and inflate some of
those argument, just assign the
values to the bundle, set it
there, and then you can route
all of this logic through your
normal fragment argument
handling that appears throughout
the rest of your fragment
implementation.
>> IAN LAKE: So one of the
other use cases we found really
useful for using fragments is
this kind of app screen kind of
model, so where a fragment is
taking the vast majority of the
screen.
It's really the main content of
your
app, and this is really kind of
where Navigation comes in and
really kind of takes away a lot
of the rough edges of fragments
so you're just left with the
architecture component hooks and
a view.
So in this model, it's a lot
easier
to move towards a single
activity app.  If you listen to
Chet yesterday, this is kind of
our recommendation going forward
to kind of use activities just
as an entry point into your app,
and then your content, the
actual things
that the UI -- the pieces that
user actually work with, are the
fragments of your  app, right,
the actual content is in
fragments.
So with this model, the only
thing the activity needs to do
is handle kind
of common app chrome.  So if
you're using an action bar still
or if you're using like bottom
Nav or side Nav, these would be
guide things that the activity
can manage, but the rest of it
could be decoupled destination,
decoupled screens, all of these
fragments can be much more
independent from each other
rather than being tightly
coupled together.
So this allows us to kind of
move a lot of the things that
normally you
would have to deal with manually
into a system that we can help
you out a lot
more on, so for navigation, for
example, we're going to give you
the hooks that
you need to set up the
transitions and animations
needed to transition between
these screens, and it's
something that can be done in
Navigation rather than something
you have to do by hand.
Of course, like these aren't
neutrally exclusive, right.
You can still add a fragment to
your layout or have nested
fragments underneath these
things, so it's not an all or
nothing kind of approach.
It's just one method  that, yes,
this
larger kind of content-based
fragment is still a really good
way of kind of bridging the gap
between the Android.
app world and the widget world.
Another use case that is
still
super useful is around dialogue
fragment.  Again, we talked
about kind of the
activity of showdialogue.  I
hope everyone forgot that now
like I said, but dialogue
fragment is really kind of the
same approach where instead
of it being something that you
need to manage and make sure is
visible or not
visible, it really kind of helps
encapsulate the interaction
between a
floating UI, like you have a
really important question to ask
the user, a dialogue is probably
a useful case in some manner,
but it's also something that
we've started to see a lot more.
In Android P, for instance, the
biometric prompt for fingerprint
is now something that is in a
dialogue kind of model, so this
is actually something
that we've found really useful.
And part of it is that we can
leverage some of that instance
state restoration that you get
for free as part of fragments
with your dialogue.  This means
that you've asked a really
important question, otherwise
why would
you show a dialogue and
interrupt the user?  But you
really don't want that to
disappear when you resize your
screen on
a pixel book orrotate your
device on the phone.  It's an
important question and we want
to make sure we do some of the
restoration state for you.
At the same point,
dialogues aren't just a floating
UI.  Right.
There are also bottom sheets and
bottom sheet dialogue fragment
specifically built around having
different kinds of floating UIs,
UIs
that live above your main don't
without necessarily being just
the like dimmed
background kind of traditional
dialogue of it.
So we're really trying to get to
this point where, yes, uses a
dialogue fragment is great if
you have this UI that you really
don't want to lose.  It's really
important for the user,
obviously for things that the
user could
use or could lose, but it's
probably not a dialogue you want
to use, it's probably a snack
bar or another approach here.
This is my favorite part
about
dialogue fragments, there is
literally nothing more you need
to do.
You call show or shownow for the
synchronous method and that's
it.  It's very much this kind of
model where we're going to do
the fragment transactions for
you.  Again, like we don't want
to be in a
model where you have to do a lot
of
complicated work yourself.
For a dialogue fragment you
can literally just call show and
it will do the right thing and
get you back into the right
state.
>> ADAM POWELL: All right. So
one of the other things that
people
tend to use fragments for quite
a bit is
managing options menus and
specifically merging menus into
a common toolbar or action bar
that's global to the activity.
So fragment support options
menus because activities support
them.  This goes back to the
design  goal,
where fragments had to do
anything the activity could do.
The most common way is set
support action bar for your
toolbar which kind
of binds whatever your current
context
is to a particular toolbar
within your UI.
This is create if you have a
fixed common chrome.  In the
navigation world, if your
toolbar never changes between
screen, then this is really
handy because this means that
you can populate that with
whatever actions are relevant
for what's in your main don't.
Fragment pager adapter is
another really great one that
people use this for quite a bit.
If the actions change across
pages, then all of this is just
kind of handled for you, the
system takes care of it.
Now, the alternative to this is
that you can go ahead and
directly
manage the menus as Toolbar View
Data.  Most of the time today
your UIs are such that the
toolbar or other sort of menu
management is really kind of
part of the content.  I mean,
this was something that you saw
back in a lot of hollow UIs
where the action bar was always
fixed common chrome, but now you
have the collapsing app bar
layouts and things that are much
more sophisticated to the point
we're doing the global wire app
is almost jumping through hoops
that you don't really need, so
don't make it more complicated
than it needs to be.  If you
don't have common chrome for
this, then directly managing
some of the toolbar menus as
View Data is as simple of this.
It's a couple lines of code.
There is not a whole lot to it.
You inflate the menu, attach a
listener, and keep it more
self-contained rather than
leaking out into the whole
options menu at that point.
One of the other things we get
asked a lot is about testing
fragments.  Testing fragments is
a whole lot easier than testing
activities.  You don't have to
spin up the entirety of the
world, entire new activity with
sort of the back and forth in an
instrumentation test to the
activity manager to make this
work.  The nice part about this
is that from
quite a few years ago, we've had
this glass fragment controller
that is able to drive the
lifecycle, so you can go ahead
and create just a test fragment
manager or test fragment
controller that can test those
larger fragment components in
isolation away from everything
else that might be happening in
the activity manager.
We use this pretty extensively
for the existing support library
tests ourselves.  Now, we make
this possible but truth be told,
this is really not the best
interface for doing it.  It ends
up looking a little bit like
this or you could go through
some of the
support library tests in AOSP
and see kind of the example of
some of the utility methods that
we've set up for this.
We should really probably wrap
this in some some type of move
to state type of method.  This
is a case where we fell into a
trap ourself, something is
possible, it's maybe not great,
the rest is kind of left as an
exercise to the reader and we
just kind of need to do better
on this part.
>> IAN LAKE: Yeah, so one of
the other pieces that kind of
came along side of fragments
more from a convenience method
than anything else were loaders.
A kind of precursor to a lot of
what we've done in architecture
components on doing retained
instance states, and one of the
things we've done recently is
actually tried to decouple them
from fragments.
So how do we actually do this?
Well, instead of being their own
special thing, we actually
rebuilt them on a lot of the
architecture components
using these new primitives we
have of
LiveData and ViewModel to make
these a totally independent
thing.  Now you can actually use
loaders in
any lifecycle owner or view
store owner class, activity,
fragment, if you're building
your own kind of thing, it works
equally well in all of those
cases.
What does this mean?  It really
just means that you have the
same loader you always do, but
instead
of calling
getsupportloader Manager, can
you just call getinstance.
We'll do all the hookup for you.
We know you're in a  lifecycle
observer and so we know how to
hook all that stuff up for you,
and we really were able to kind
of cut out a lot of
the stuff -- cut out a lot of
the custom behavior here so
that, you know, we can kind of
rely on these new things to give
you stronger guarantees around
lifecycle.
So we've talked a lot about
fragments and we've talked a lot
about fragments in the past and
we've talked
about fragments in 2018, but
there is another question.
Where are we going with
fragments?  What do we still
have to do?
So some of this is just coming
down to building in those
stronger guarantees, trying to
separate the desired behavior,
things that we
specifically set out to put in
versus incidental behavior, more
behavior that
has just been around for six
years and
is not necessarily something
that is a codified standard.
We're trying to move more toward
a model where you can be very
confident in exactly what's
going to happen when you're
using fragments.
Another case is trying to
do the
same thing that we did with
Loader Manager in reimplementing
some of these existing APIs on
top of these new primitives.
For example, like being able to
rewrite a lot of the internals
of fragments so they're actually
using lifecycle observers under
the covers, right.  So these
kind of things allow us to
kind of make sure that all of
our components are on the same
page and really doing the same
thing.
So a few other things.
Again, trying to move towards a
world
where we have the correct set of
signals and activity callbacks
so that any
interested component can be it.
That means that fragments are
not a special snowflake anymore
and they're just another
component, another tool in
your toolbox using the same
composable hooks that you always
have.  So really trying to play
well with other components so
that it's not an either/or and
it's a both.  We can work
together, that you can use
fragments a I long
long side other components and
it works.
>> ADAM POWELL: So options are
of course one other thing that
we still don't have a great
answer for this in terms of how
we want to decouple this.  In in
a lot of ways I would like
options menus as a concept to be
depricated but we have to make
sure you have them for when
you're using common chrome or
paging through some don't.
Next one?  Maybe?  There we go.
Android.app.fragment manager.
It's deprecated.
This works a lot better in the
Android packages and support
before it because this means you
no longer have to wore bee all
the bugs that were fixed over
time and allows us to make
larger changes to the behave in
API.  Send us your wish list for
the things you would like to see
us do for some of this too.  We
are going to be in the sandbox
area after this so please come
and say hello and tell us what
you would like to see next.
Thank you very much for coming.
(Applause).
(music)
.
>> Thank you for joining
the session.
Ambassadors will assist with
letting you through the
designated exits.  We'll be
making room for those that
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session, we ask that you please
leave
the room and return via the line
outside.  Thank you.
May 9, 2018
9:30 a.m.
PT
What's New in Android Things?
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> At this time, please
find your seat.  Our session
will begin soon.
>> Good morning and welcome
to the second day of Google I/O.
Thank you all who made it here
bright and early and a big hello
to folks on the live stream.
This session is about Android
Things,
the version of Android that was
specifically designed for IoT
products.  My name is Vince and
I lead product management for
Android Things.  Yesterday you
heard about incredible momentum
on Android.  Over the years we
have extended Android to many
different types of devices
beyond phones and tablets,
wearables, TVs, auto, and last
year we announce add new version
of Android called Android
Things, specifically
designed for embedded devices in
IoT products.
I know many of you have been
tracking our regular developer
previews and are already
building great things.  I love
reading about the project, it's
so awesome.
For some of you, this is
entirely new you're just getting
started and want to know what
Android Things can do for  you,
so let me just get started with
some of the obvious questions.
What is Android Things for?
What problems does it solve?
People have been making
connected devices for many
years.  What's different now is
the profound revolution in
Machine Learning.  Powerful
models and tools are available
for all developers and there is
ever increasing demand for
smarter devices
Traditionally, your only option
when building smarter devices
was to delegate some of the
serious processing to the Cloud.
Now, it's possible to run much
of it
on device which is useful if you
need low latency or handling
sensitive don't and so on.  And
this growing area is exactly
where Android Things is
targeted.
It is for  devices that need
powerful on-device intelligence.
When we look around the
devices that populate your
homes and businesses, IoTs, of
course, are very broad and
diverse, so in a sense the
product categories are all
familiar.  We all know these.
It's just the user expectations
have gone up, way up.  Let me
just pick on two use cases
At home, we increasingly expect
to be able to talk to our
devices and they'll know who we
are.
Another one is  Smart Building
devices such as cameras that can
now detect how many people are
in a room and do something
useful with that, for example
talk to the HVAC system.  We
know users want these kind of
devices and we know we could
build them, but of course
building these devices is
actually very hard, especially
maintaining them over time.
It's actually very expensive to
do this.  We know this at Google
because we've been shipping
these kinds of products.
What's so hard?  Well first off,
we're talking about an
entire device, so a whole
physical
product so responsible for the
entire software stack from the
bottom up to the product
experience.  Now of course the
product experience is where you
ideally want to spend most of
your time because that's where
users
are spending and interacting
with it.  Below the product
experience, IoT
devices are currently built
using many different flavors of
roll your own Linux
or Android, and every d device
is different.
It's hard to expect consistent
and
reliable APIs.  When you go from
project to project
you want to reuse what you
built, you want to get support
from a large community.
At the same time, we're
talking about richer
experiences with these
devices, so obviously you need
to get your app working, chances
are you need to get  third-party
apps and services working.  Each
time you need to figure out
basic
building blocks like a reliable
setup flow from a smart phone
for instance.  You could do it
all yourself, but it just feels
like extra time and effort.
Second, when you get down
to the
hardware, building prototypes
with microprocessor SoCs have
gotten easier over time.  People
use all sorts of prototyping
tools to get that done, but
those don't get you through to
production, let alone commercial
launch.
We're talking about PCP design
and layout involving high speed,
highly integrate the components,
SoC vendor relationships for
general support and bring up
component supplychain, access to
parts in low volume, and so on.
These are all very different
skillsets that you need to hire
for your team.
Again, prototyping solutions get
you off the ground, but that's
it.
Finally, while it's amazing how
much these devices can do on our
behalf these days, the flip
side, of course, is that they
have the keys to our home, our
businesses, our banking systems.
Clearly there is more to gain
from attacking IoT devices.
Perhaps less obvious is why it's
hard to provide the security
Well, it turns out it's
incredibly
expensive to provide on products
out of the gate and keep them
updated over  time.
It involves a lot of backend
infrastructure to do this, and
with he know this at Google
because we've been doing this
for many products.
Meanwhile there is immense
cost pressure from end
consumers, of course,
and it's hard
toamortize costs without large
volume.
So those are the issues that our
engineering teams and business
teams focused on when we built
Android Things.
The thinking was we could take
care of all the challenges that
make development expensive, we
provide Android Things free of
charge and you have less to
worry about.  Our goal is to
reduce the barrier to building
powerful, intelligent edge
devices and make it more
accessible to everyone.
Now, let's take a look deeper.
About building on reliable and
consistent APIs, Android Things
is Android.  As you would
expect, you can rely on
the same Android APIs and Google
services as when you build for
phones.  Familiar tools such as
Android Studio
and the Android SDK are
available.
You can build on Google Play
services,
Google Cloud Platform, Firebase
and the MLkit that you heard
about yesterday and more
Of course, you're building
hardware and so it's also about
component providers, SoC vendors
and so on.  As a device maker,
usually you spend a lot of time
interacting directly to get to a
working image.  With Android
Things, we've already done the
hard work for you and that means
you have access to hardware
reference designs, it means the
build support package comes from
Google, and
you get a working image right
away.
You can scale to production
because we've signed agreements
with the SoC vendors to
guarantee support over the long
term.  Literally, our goal is if
you know how to build an Android
app you can now prototype IoT
products and take them all the
way to production.  You don't
have to be a hardware
engineer or firmware engineer to
do this.
Finally, on security, our
strategy is to have security
features built into the
platform.
Os hardening is on by default
and you don't have to spend time
figuring it out yourself.  What
about fixes over time?  Regular
security patches come regularly
from Google.  Google provides
all the backend infrastructure
for you to be in control,
and you can decide when those go
out.
Now, let's go a bit deeper.  How
do all the pieces that I just
talked about fit together?
Developers often ask me, how is
Android Things different from
Android?
How is it different from AOSP?
I found that the best way
to describe Android Things is
that it's a
fully managed solution beyond an
AOSP model.
At the lowest level we define
turnkey hardware in partnership
with the silicon providers, this
is on a form of system
module architecture and I'll
talk about more on that in a bit
The way it works though is
we work
closely with SoCs to land code
in the Google tree.  Google is
hosting the BSPs.  In fact, we
have the system in our test labs
looked up for continuous
integration.
Moving up to Android in the
framework layers, Android Things
is Android.  What we've done is
we took Android and
we shrunk it down to around 50%
of the
footprint of AOSP, it can run
with lower compute and storage
requirements.
Security features are built
in, meaning they're done for you
and they're on by default.
Up at the top is the app layer.
We formalized a boundary so all
the  product-specific code lives
there.  We make sure the Google
services you might want to work
with work well out of
the box so your apps can rely on
Google
Play Services,  Firebase, Cloud
Platform, Assistant, and more
Finally, what's pictured on
the
left side is the management
console.
It shows everything from bottom
to top because it's where you
control everything that goes
into your device, where you get
access to the BSP that Google
and SoC vendors are supporting,
it's where you create full
product builds with all your
apps and services included, it's
where you manage releases and
update channels over time.
As you can see, that's why
I described Android Things as a
fully managed solution.  It
gives you portfolio of reference
hardware to choose from, it
gives you Android with security,
and key services working on top.
It gives you console to
configure what exactly goes into
your  devices.  It's all of the
ingredients necessary
to prototype and scale to
production.
On behalf of the entire
Android Things team, I'm super
excited to share that we are now
generally available.  Version
170 is the first long-term
supported release.  Came out two
days ago on Monday, fresh off
the suppress.  Many of you have
helped us along the way.  We've
seen more than 100,000 downloads
of the Android Things SDK.
We've received feedback from
more than 10,000 developers and
it's all critical to get us to
this point.  Thank you so much.
Now, what does Version 1.0
mean for you?  Most importantly,
it means Android Things is a
stable base for you to build
commercial products.  In fact,
we've worked with a few partners
to put Android Things through
its paces and vet whether we
could power real shipping
products.
Let me show you a few.
What you see here is our first
shipping product and it really
put our program to the test.
This is a smart speaker by LG
and it landed on shelfs last
month.
So the story is LG wanted to
build a smart speaker with
high-end audio and go to market
quickly and they felt we would
be a good fit.
One of the first things was
to determine a good hardware
reference design.  The system
module architecture that we
talked about before is in all
the shipping  products.
From your point of view, it is
all done so you can just pick it
up, it will be an officially
supported platform and you're
good to go.
Well, LG was also concerned
about ongoing security  fixes
and
infrastructure to send over the
air updates.  Bottom line these
guys want to work on
amazing audio and not staff up a
team to do security and do OS
bringup.  This is smart speaker
so it's
nontrivial audio processing and
audiocrafting for Google
assistant, we make sure they
work well and they're part of
the full solution as well
There is more OEMs working
on smart speakers and they'll be
coming out in retail soon.
Soon after, partner chose us for
a new category called Smart
Displays, the
idea is a visual Google
assistant, deep integration with
photos, maps, video calling,
YouTube, and so on.
What you see are devices from
Lenovo, JBL and LG.  All of
these guys wanted to move
quickly and they felt that we
could help them do that.
at the time, we were
already
working with SoC vendors,
expanding our portfolio and we
were locked in a common system
module for all of these
products.  In other words, if
you looked under
the hood, all of them are using
the same system-on module which
is quite cool.  Again, when you
work on your project, you can
just skip all of that upfront
SoC work and just pick up the
supported design.
The OEMs were also concerned
about ongoing updates especially
because this is a new product
category.  They're expecting
frequent updates and during
development, they wanted to
partition folks into different
groups and test the user
experience.
This is where our console was
put to
the test to manage all the
builds, release channels, and
frequent updates
Of course, IoT is broad and
diverse.  What's the most
exciting for me is see being
what everyone has been building
based on our developer previews.
Here are two examples.
The product on the right is
made by
a company called byteflies, a
wearable startup based in
Belgium.
The hand is holding a sensor
that monitors vital signs and it
sends the data back to the
Cloud.
They let us know Android Things
helped turn the docking station
into a secure hub.  They don't
have to worry about ongoing
fixes and how to update the
device
The product on the left is made
by
a couple called Mirego based in
Montreal.
Built a network of public things
and
connected to a photobooth in
downtown Montreal that sounds
really fun.  They wanted a
solution to help them move
quickly and Android could help
them do that.  If you're
building a new product by
Android Things, we want to work
with you too.
We introduced a special limited
program to partner with the
Android
Things team for technical
guidance and support.  If your
company is interested in
learning more, please let us
know at the link.
So now that I've shown you
some real products, let's switch
gears and go back to how all the
pieces fit together starting
from the bottom.  We talked
about the hardware reference
designs, we talked about the
system
modules, you might be wondering,
what do they actually look like?
So on the right here is a
system-on-module.  SoM for
short.
It's the NXP, IMX7D.  All of the
complicated components are in
the SoM.  The key component such
as the SoC,
memory, flash, WiFi, Bluetooth,
the baseboard is what you see on
the left.  This one shown here
is actually one of our
development baseboards, but you
can
imagine  designing
product-specific baseboards with
just the right set of
connectors and plugging the SoM
on top.
The SoM is complicated and quite
costly to design if you were to
do it yourself, and we've done
the hard work for you.  It would
also be very expensive at low
volume, but the SoMs are what
everyone will be using and that
helps drive up volume for
everyone.
The baseboards are much
less expensive to produce, even
at lower quantities.  The
electronics are much lower speed
and less dense.
What I've shown here is also
referred to as a physical SoM
because the SoM is on its own
board.
You can also imagine designing
it in so it's all on one single
board and we call that the
virtual SoM.
This would allow you to save on
costs at high volume or to
better match XY dimensions for
your product.  Going back to the
three Smart Displays I showed
earlier, they all use different
tactics, some use physical SoMs
and some design it in virtually.
For each SoM, Google hosts the
board support package,  BSP for
short.  In other words, you
don't have to interact with the
SoC vendors.  There is a stable
layer of separation with the BSP
that makes the code portable.
You could imagine starting
development on one SoM and then
swopping to another at later
stages of production if your
design changes without having to
change your code.
Now, part of making the SoM
architecture viable is
guaranteed support.  Behind the
scenes we've been working really
hard with the SoC vendors to
work out the collaboration so
you don't have
to talk directly to them.  We
are announcing SoMs that are
certified for production.  The
list includes hardware from
Mediatek, NXP and Qualcomm.
More specifically, SoMs on
this list have guaranteed
long-term support and all
security features built in,
making it possible to bring
prototypes and go all the way to
production.
Hardware and reference designs
for these SoMs will be available
in the coming months, so stay
tuned.
SoMs supported for development
is already available  now.
Hardware from RaspberryPi and
NXP.  Development hardware have
a large community of support and
are readily
available in retail even at unit
equal tees, usually for cheap.
The beautiful thing about the
Android model is you can swop
over to SoMs and certified for
production once you're ready
Everyone has been
wondering, for the list of SoMs
that are certified for
production, the ones on the
left, how long is the support
and how much does it cost?
Each SoM certified for
production is supported by
Google for a minimum of three
years from the time it was first
made available.  What this means
is you will get regular security
patches and stability fixes from
Google for you to push to your
devices.  You can even set your
devices to auto-update and not
worry about it.
In other words, you get to
fully harness the power of the
Android Security Team.  Of
course, you can push your own
updates to your devices any time
you want for the entire product
lifetime.
What about fees?  There are no
charges to using Android Things.
There are no license fees for
the OS or the management
console.
The API surface is stable,
meaning the length of support is
provided for each major version.
This is why we refer to 1.0 as
long-term support.  We know
moving to a new major version
can be disruptive and it may not
make sense for many IoT product,
so there is no need to do that.
Let me show you in a bit
more detail.  Each line on this
chart represents a major version
of Android Things, and of course
2.0, 3.0 in the future.
As I said, every measured
version will have long-term
support, the minimum three years
we talked about.  These major
versions do map to underlying
Android deserts and will pick
the right  points to intersect
over time
The important point is when 2.0
comes out, 1.0 and 2.0 are
supported in parallel.
The security patches and
stability fixes come regularly
and that's what
each white dot in the lines
represent, and we'll also have
minor feature updates on the
latest major version, so this is
so we continue to address
community feedback in a timely
manner.  So we won't wait for
the next major version to push
these out.
In fact, in the coming
months, 1.
1 will come out with
improvements for you.
One last note on SoMs.
Obviously the work we do behind
the scenes with the SoM vendors
is never ending.  It's an
ongoing process.  We'll continue
to expand the SoM portfolio.
You saw the vendors that already
have something listed
officially, and we're
deeply engaged with others too
like Rockship.
The point is once we put a SoM
up as certified for production,
it's a commitment.  The ones you
saw all support 1.0 and when we
eventually add 2.0, we'll be
explicit about which SoMs
support it.
Now, we've been talkings about
the next layer up already since
Google supports the support
package for every SoM, but what
does it actually look like.
Let's go into that in a little
bit more detail
What you see here is a
simplified software stack for a
traditional Android Mobile
Device.  Going from bottom to
top, the kernel up to the HAL
layers is primarily focused on
enabling hardware support.  The
Android framework provides a
rich
set of experiences for apps and
the applications provide useful
features, right.
In IoT devices you can
imagine many
of the included components not
making sense.  Well, you know,
embedded devices are usually
single purpose, they may not
have a screen, users are not
installing apps, and so on.
So first Android Things removed
most of the user-facing
applications and
visual of course framework
components that don't make
sense.  There is no use for a
messaging app.  This removes
unnecessary complexity and
reduces the footprint of the
distribution.
If you build a device with
a display, you have full
control.  There is no system UI
to get in the way.
Now with or without a display,
the UI toolkit portions of the
framework remain available to
the apps.  Activities are still
the primary component of an
Android app.  The  framework
delivers all input events to the
foreground activity which has
focus.
Next, we formalized the
boundary between the system and
a product-specific code
necessary for the device.
Product specific code is above
the line in the app layer.
Everything below the line is
provided by Google and our SoC
partners.  This way you don't
have to figure out how to put
together a working image.
Google can sign the full image
and
guarantee automatic security
over the support timeframe
You might be wondering how can
this work in practice?  Well,
one crucial piece is the Android
Things Support  Library.  I'll
touch upon the API surface
briefly.  For example, you may
be wondering how to control
hardware.
The peripheral I/O API allows
apps to interface with
low level peripherals using
industry protocols like GPIO.
It allows apps to inject
hardware events into the Android
framework.
You might be wondering how
to call APIs that usually
involve a dialogue or view to
the user.  These don't make
sense when displays are
optional.  So we've added APIs
to control settings, control
device updates, and configure
local area connectivity
including Bluetooth and LoWPAN
I'd like to show you the
complete picture.  We've already
talked about the portfolio of
SoMs you can select from and
these come in at the bottom.
There are actually two more
building blocks.  The first is
device configuration and the
second is security.
Let's start with device
configuration.  It's the other
crucial piece along
with the Android Things Support
Library that helps maintain the
formal like we talked about.
SoMs can support a wide variety
of
hardware and so in many cases
the OS has to know which is
connected in order to properly
connect those interfaces.
For instance, which audio
devices
are connected where and their
formats?
We provide a configuration
system so  OEMs can is divide
the connected hardware in the
console which will correspond
the image at build time
Cool, let's talk a little
bit about security.
First off, the OS hardening that
we do on Android is enabled to
Android Things so these are
things like permissions, the
application sandbox, mandatory
access control with SELinux.
Kernel Cisco filtering and so
on.  Images of sign, you don't
need to run any signing
infrastructure yourself.  Google
provides the infrastructure to
build the full image for you.
These partitions are signed for
security.  Verified boot, which
is full he'd implemented for
SoMs certified for production,
make sure you're running a valid
image at all times
There is lots of interesting
scenarios that are handled for
you, and I always get a kick of
thinking about them.  For
example, what about running an
older image with a vulnerability
that's since been fixed?  Robot
protection makes sure this
doesn't happen.
Another one is product  key, so
images only run where intended.
You can ensure only your product
images run on your devices
Finally you don't need to
run update infrastructure.
Google takes care of building
and serving updates, the same
infrastructure
we use for our own products
All right.  Now we're
moving on to the app layer where
all of the product-specific code
lives.  What does building an
app on Android
Things look like?
To get started, we want access
to the Android thing  Support
Library we talked about.  Built
into the shared devices as a
shared library.
We're showing code snippets from
two files here.
At the top is a snippet from the
file.  Declare the SDK
dependency there and it will get
pulled in.  The bottom is a
snippet of the Android manifest
file, and you notice we use the
user's library tag so the app
can access the device's shared
library.  Below that is
supplying the HOME
category to one of your
activities.  What this does is
the system will launch the
activity automatically on boot
and relaunch it if the app
terminates.  This is of course
exactly the behavior you would
expect for embedded devices.
Now that we have this set up,
let's do something  useful.  The
example here is very simple.  It
detects a button press, but it's
a good demonstration of how to
interface directly with
peripherals using the
peripheral I/O API.  The code at
the top is the Android manifest
file.  This is where we declare
the required permissions to use
peripheral I/O.  The code
snippet below is the activity.
There we use the peripheral I/O
API to
open a connection to a GPO pin
which is where the button is
connected, and we configure the
GPIO pin as an input and attach
a callback and that's pretty
much it.  Good to go.
A similar workflow is used for
all
of the peripheral I/O interfaces
so you can imagine adding a few
lines and you can light up an
LED.
Of course, it's not just about
simple stuff.  There is a wide
variety of peripherals out
there.  Your app can interact
with all kinds
of sensors, actuators and so on
this way.
we've expanded our community hub
this week as part of the 1.0
announcement.
The site is
Androidthings.withgoogle.com.
It brings together all of the
information in one place,
samples, documents, forum.
Also, as you probably guess,
much of the code we showed
before about driving hardware
peripherals isn't exactly
product specific.  You can get
up and running quickly
with prebuilt drivers from my
peripheral driver library.
These drivers extract a low
level communication details
associated with many common
hardware peripherals, you can
browse the driver library at the
community hub, and we're also
now expecting -- accepting
community contributions as well,
so let's all make this better
together.  Be sure to check that
out.
Where do you go from here?
You have full access to the
Android SDK and NDK when
building apps.  You can use
Android Studio, develop your
apps, leverage standard
developer tools and third-party
libraries.
Many projects find Google Play
Services, Firebase, Google Cloud
Platform, et cetera, very
useful.  In fact, you can create
an  end-to-end demo very
quickly.  For instance, if
you're collecting sensor data,
you can use Cloud IoT Core
to help youingest data and do
something with it in the Cloud
If you're taking photo, the
Cloud Vision API, for example,
can help you with object
detection.  Of course, there is
a lot more it.  We'll have many
samples in the
community site for you to check
out.
Let's say a bit more about
Google Play Services because
we've created an optimized
lighter weight version of that
for Android Things.  It's
optional so it doesn't take up
space if you don't need it.
Many developers do find it very
useful though.
You can literally take a
checkbox and add it to your
build from the console.
You can find a Firebase APIs in
there which are used in many of
our  samples.  For example, the
realtime database is very useful
when you sync device data.
You can also use the new MLkit
to integrate Google's Machine
Learning technology into your
app.
There is of course a lot more in
Play Services, a few location
APIs,
nearby for setup, maps, and
more.
The final piece to Android
Things is a console for managing
what's running on your devices.
It's shown vertically cutting
across everything from bottom to
top because that's where you
manage all the builds and
releases for your entire device
fleet at every stage of the
product development process.
Let me explain.  Here is a very
simplified view of the product
development flow.  Every product
goes through the prototyping
phase where you just want to get
something working, then a series
of hardware validation
manufacturing stages, and
finally commercial launch.
At the beginning, you're
going to pick up one of the
development SoMs because that's
the easiest thing to do, and
then later swop to one of the
SoMs certified for production.
After you get the hardware, you
might
be wondering well, how do I
assemble an image and push it to
the device?
In the prototyping phase, you
probably just want quick access
to a generic image to get you
going.
You might only care about one
device, so you go to the console
and tell it which SoM you've
chosen and that's pretty much
it.
You can then flash the image and
siloed apps to your device
As your product evolves you come
back to the console to customize
a lot more.  For instance, you
may want to change
the partition sizes, you may
want to include Google Play
Services because your apps need
it, you may want to
modify the de device
configuration build time based
on the  peripherals, you may
start caring about a lot more
devices.
For the Smart Displays and
smart speaker devices that we
showed earlier, the OEMs use the
console to split the
devices into groups, so
developers, QA, early beta
testers, they're all in
different groups, they all have
different builds, and on
different update channels.
All of this is configured from
the console.  When you go to
production, you
obviously need to assemble --
I'm sorry.  Previous slide.
When you go to production, you
obviously need to assemble the
entire factor image that
includes apps and services.  You
want to update your app over the
lifetime of the device.  It's
important to have control over
rollout.
For example, roll back if
something goes wrong.  Gradual
percentage rollup so you can go
slow and check that things are
going well.  Access to metrics
so you can see that things are
going in the right direction.
All of this is why the console
exists.  The underlying  backend
infrastructure is the same as
what Google uses for our own
products.
So I just finished explaining
how Android Things is a fully
managed solution.
We have a lot more to show you
at I/O.  Come and see us at our
sandbox dome, it's the giant
bright orange one, it's hard to
miss.  The entire dome is filled
with Android Things demos.  You
can see how real commercial
products evolve from prototype
to production, Smart Display,
you can see them all there.
We talked about devices getting
increasingly smarter, we have
demos showing Machine Learning,
ingesting realtime video so it
can recognize emotion, faces,
handwriting and so on.
By the way, you notice Android
Things powering devices outside
of the dome as well.  It's
powering the survey boxes all
around I/O for instant feedback.
There is a five-foot tall robot
roaming around somewhere, hard
to miss that one, Android Things
in there.  If you like to code,
come to our codelabs and get
hands on.  We have one showing
how to work with TensorFlow,
Cloud IoT, how we make the
survey box and more.
There is eight more
sessions coming up today and
tomorrow that go deeper into
specific topics.  For example,
the session at 11:30 today talks
about how we built the Smart
Display product, the journey all
the way from prototype to
production.  The last session we
have tomorrow talks about the
console in detail and
how to manage your devices at
different stages of the
development process.
Finally, let's all have
some fun at
I/O, join our scavenger hunt at
the link.  You might have seen
this already.  There is very
cool Machine Learning enhanced
flowers that you'll notice,
solve the puzzles and you get a
free hardware developer kit.
With that, let's all go
build some hardware.  If you
know thousand build an Android
app, you now have a new
superpower.  You can prototype
IoT products and bring them all
the way to production with
Android Things.  You don't have
to be a hardware engineer or
firmware engineer to do this.
Pick up a kit from the scavenger
hunt and head to Android Things.
withgoogle.com to get started.
This concludes the talk.  My
name is Vince.  Thank you and
good luck.
(Applause)
this session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits.  We'll be
making room for those who have
registered for the next session.
If you've registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
May 9, 2018
10:30 a.m.
PT
A Fresh Look at Advanced cop
topics
for
advanced Topics for Android
Experts
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> RETO MEIER: Wow.
(Applause).
>> RETO MEIER: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, the
Developer Advocate here at
Google.
Technically, I'm a DA on the
Google
Cloud dev rel team.  So if any
of you bump into my boss or
anyone from the Google Cloud
Team and they ask how the
presentation went, if you could
tell them that I presented how
to build a Cloud  backend mobile
app, that would really help me
out.
What I am present something
hopefully what everyone is here
to see,
Android Protips, a fresh look at
expert advice for advanced
Android developers.
As the title suggestions,
this is a lot of technical talk.
There will be a lot of code.  If
you're not  comfortable with
code
and you came to see the Grateful
Dead, you're in the wrong place
and also about 20 years late.
To make sure we have the
right people in the  audience,
how many of you are developing
for Android right now?  Not now,
now, but at home and at work?
Most of you, not everyone.
That's cool, like there are some
Android curious folks here, some
Dead Heads in the wrong place
and time.  Some folks on the
bank working on their tan, and
that's cool, too.  Everyone is
welcome.  Thank you for coming.
Now, this is actually a
pretty special year for Android.
This marks the 10-year
anniversary of Android
development, which is super
exciting.  Obviously not
everyone has been
developing an Android quite that
long.  How many of you have been
developing for more than two
years?  Yeah?  Wow.  Five years?
A few hands down.  What about 10
years?  Do we have any 10-year
veterans?  A few.  Nice!
Congratulations!  Yeah, a round
of applause for the 10 years.
(Applause).
I too have that honor, that
privilege of having been
developing for Android for 10
years, I even brought receipts.
This is my very first question
on
stack  overflow, asking about
the maps API for the .
9 beat-it SDK so the 10-year
veterans will remember and
hopefully not remember, this is
not my first Googler,
and not my first  Protip
section.  This will be the last
question I ask for a little
while.  How many have been to a
previous I/O and seen one of my
previous Protips sections.  A
descent  handful.  All right.
And you still came to this!
(laughter).
That's reassuring, so thank
you for that.  I actually spend
a fair bit of time over the last
couple of months looking back
over these session, and at first
it was because I wanted to gain
some inspiration, you know, like
what are the cool things we used
to talk about, gain some of the
excitement from the early days
of Android.
But I quickly realized that not
everything that I had said in
those
early days has held up all that
well.
So as a result, what I'm
actually going to be presenting
this year is looking at all the
things that we've said in
previous years and giving it a
bit of an update.  So the real,
real title slide for
today's session is actually,
Android Protips Fixed.
(laughter).
I'm sorry.  So the goal
here is to provide you with all
the tip, tricks, best practices,
and good advice that's going to
help us develop great apps for
the next decade of Android
development, and in order to do
that effectively, I want to you
take the same journey as me.  So
we're going to start by going
back in time.  We're going to go
back through
previous Google I/Os, previous
Protips sessions, all the way
back to the very, very
beginning.
(laughter).
We may have gone too far
back.
This is me in kindergarten, a
happy child.  I don't know what
a fragment is and I've never
heard of a content provider.
(laughter).
That will change.  Also, a
side note.
I didn't know I was presenting
in the amphtheater and there
would be a  400-foot screen, and
if I had known that I may have
included fewer pictures of
myself.  Take note if you're
ever in this situation.
Clearly we're too far back
so let's just pump it a few
years forward, I think I can do
that with one of these button,
let's have a look.  Yes.  Yeah.
This is more like it.  Don't I
look young?  This is 2008 and I
remember this because this is
actually the cover photo for my
first Android book and we took
this photo just after I had
gotten the first round of editor
notes back from
the first draft, and the next
day Android release the the 1.0
SDK and up until then I was
writing based on the .9 beta.  I
knew it was coming, the clue is
in the name, but I figured how
much is going to change.  1.0
from .9.  .8 to .9 was minor, so
it should just be a couple
little things.  Turns out a lot
can change.  Like really a lot.
(laughter).
I had actually written an entire
chapter on the GTalk data API.
It was pretty cool but didn't
exist in the 1.0 SDK.  30 pages
of hard work.  I didn't remove
it.  I ended up leaving it in
the book because by the time it
came out, who knows, right.
Android moves quickly.  It's
been 10 years.  It never got put
back in and
eventually I removed it it from
future revisions of the book.
The reason I mention this
is because I spent most of the
past 10 years going around
talking about Android, giving
advice on the best way of doing
things, the latest and greatest
APIs that you can take advantage
of to build great apps.
And I do this with the knowledge
that sometimes within months and
even weeks, and these things are
going to change.  They're going
to be replaced with something
more efficient, more
comprehensive, and in fact weeks
and months is a best case
scenario.  I remember one
particular incident.  I had just
finished a keynote.
Very exciting, a developer day
in Prauge I think it was, what's
new in  cupcake.  I've been
doing this for a while.  I
stepped off stage and as my foot
hit the ground we released
doughnut, and in that instance I
had 3 nanoseconds of being
current before everything I said
was effectively outdated.
Now despite how all of that may
sound, this is actually a really
good thing.  Well for you and
not so much for me.  For you
it's a good thing.  It
demonstrates how quickly Android
is
evolving to take advantage or to
give
users and developers the things
they need to be able to be
successful.
There has always been a
tradeoff and I know you all have
felt this pain.  New platform
comes out, also new API, great
new functionality to take
advantage of, but you know it's
going to take a while before
lots of users are on
that platform, and at the same
time you know all the platforms
are going to take a few years
before they go away, so you have
to do this tradeoff.  Is it
worth putting in the time and
effort to take advantage of the
new API, the new functionality,
knowing that it's going to have
to be backwards compatible and
you'll have to maintain that
code, potentially for years, so
when do you do that?
Well, the thing is, what makes
us really excited is now we have
Jetpack which incorporates all
of the Android
Support Library, Android
Architecture components and if
you take Jetpack and combine
with Google Play Services we end
up with a increasing surface
area of APIs which don't rely on
having the latest platform
version, so you can take
advantage of the new
functionality that's available
and we'll take care of writing
all of the boilerplate code to
make it backwards compatible for
you.
Right, so this is a nice
advantage, right.  Suddenly that
tradeoff isn't quite as
expensive.
Now, it's still one of the big
pluses of this as well is we're
no longer tied to the framework,
right.  So we can continue to
launch new
features, fix bug, encapsulate
more best
practices, take care of
education and do all of this
between releases.  It's great
for developers, not so great for
those of us trying to talk about
it, things change more rapidly.
There is a price, if you
want to take advantage of this
cool new stuff, you have to
reconsider some of the
fundamental architectural
changes in how we build our app,
so I'm going to talk today a
little bit about why I think is
the right time to do that.
If we bring it down to the
real fundamentals, what we're
trying to do is
keep our app looking fresh,
lightweight, full of potential.
If not, we quickly risk becoming
visibly older, outdated, a
little bloated maybe, harder to
maintain,
harder to manage, and there is
an analogy for high cholesterol
but I couldn't figure it out.
You get the idea, right.
So before we sort of dive into
some of the tips, which we do
need to update.  I did want to
spend just a little bit of time
highlighting a handful of
protips which have stood the
test of
time, that like a fine wine or
sharp cheddar, actually age
pretty well.
There is probably more than
just the ones on this list, but
this is the highlight, and what
you'll notice about
these particular protips is
they're not really specific to
Android.  They're not even
really specific to mobile
development.  This is just good
best practice that you should
always be keeping in mind when
building any engineering app.
So let's not dwell too much on
the things that we know are
still good ideas.  Let's take a
look at some of the things which
have changed, which have perhaps
not aged quite as well.
Now, everything on this list you
can pretty much still do, but
it's all been replaced with
newer APIs that are more
efficient, that encapsulate a
bigger amount of functionality.
Sometimes the underlying
hardware is  changed or the UI
paradigm has changed, but a lot
of it you can still do.
That's actually kind of a theme
for a lot of the things that
we're going to be looking at.
There has always been ways of
achieving certain things, but
there is now significantly
better way, simpler
ways which involve less work,
less hackie workarounds and
making it more  predictable and
easier for you to manage and
maintain your code bases going
forward.
So we know things have changed.
I've said that a few times, but
there are certain things we've
always been able to rely on,
right.  You write your Android
code in Java
language syntax, and all of the
application components are
basically the same.
We use the same core components,
they interact the same way, they
achieve the same end results.
That's something we've been able
to rely on until, basically,
until now.
Last year or so, things have
fundamentally changed.  Android
Studio 3 introduced Column as a
first-class language for Android
development and that's actually
what we're encouraging people to
use as their primary developing
language for Android.
We saw the introduction of
Android Architecture components
which introduced view models,
live data and the room database
to significantly simplify the
way we manage data and have it
interact properly with the
activity  lifecycle.
We also have the job scheduling,
which almost entirely eliminates
the need to create your own
custom background services.  And
the intent receive is that we
sometimes set up to monitor
device state to control when our
services are run,
which is a good thing, because
in
Android we depricated to have
long-running services when your
app is in the background as
well.  And most of the intent
used to monitor
device state have also largely
been depricated.
Job scheduler, already
depracated as of yesterday
morning, so now we have work
manager, which is nice because
it
does the same stuff as job
scheduler but backwards
compatible, right, so you're
starting to see some of the
trends of what we're trying to
achieve here.
We should dig into some of this
stuff in a little more detail.
Something of which I've talked
about
at most of the protip session,
the first thing I talked about
and it comes up every year.  I
like to focus on what's
happening in the background.
(laughter).
Sometimes it's easy to miss
until you really focus on it.
So the first protip I gave back
in 2010, the first session, the
first Android session, the first
real session on a big stage.  It
was very exciting.  And this is
the first protip so I thought
let's have a look at what I said
and see how well it holds up.
This is the first thing I ever
advised.
>> So it's important that you
move anything which can in any
way take
longer than just a fraction of a
second and interrupt the UI flow
and move it into the backend.
The most simple and
straightforward is
to use Java threading.
What we've created in
Android is a
class called  asynctask.
(Applause).
>> RETO MEIER: You know
what they say, the giant screen
actually removes 20 pounds.
(laughter).
So it's kind of true, right.
Like kind of, like we don't want
to block the UI thread but the
context around what I was
talking about is trying to
eliminate these application not
responding dialogues which have
evolved over the years, they
look a little bit different now.
They used to be very common
because it
was easy to block the foreground
thread.  Right, if you tried to
do a data transfer, for example,
it would block and that would be
a bad experience and so with the
Android 3.0 we introduced a
runtime exception so if you
tried to access the Internet
through our runtime exception
the app would crash.  Strong
encouragement for developers not
to do that.  More recently we've
done similar things with file
system access and with database
access as well.
Now in Android P this is no
longer
a problem because we don't show
dialogue, we just crash the app,
so that's not a better outcome
for your users, but it's a much
stronger signal to us as
developers that we need to make
sure that we're taking care of
this particular problem.
Now, I did mention one solution
and
it got some love, the old
asynctask.
It's a reasonable solution to
the  stated problem.  We need to
move everything back off the
foreground on to a background
thread and that's what
asynctask does.
It creates a background threat
and has handles marshal back to
the UI thread so you can update
when you have progress or final
result to display.
I would like to tell you
that the only thing missing from
that is that now
you have to write it in
kartlin, it's better, it looks
nicer, it's more concise, but
you still have the same
fundamental problems where if
you're doing this stuff in an
activity, if the user rotates
the phone, your
thread is killed, your
asynctask, you
may leak  context, try to update
a UI element that doesn't exist,
in the
process of getting killed and
back, it's problematic.
Back in the first I/O session I
had a solution for this, it was
a great solution.
The advice was you should move
it to a
service, which it's fair to say
this
advice has not aged aged
spectacularly well.  It's the
same principle, you have
something long running.  You're
in the activity, you use an
intend to start a service,
probably an intent service and
that goes and does the time
consuming work, maybe it's
pulling something down from a
server or interacting with a
database or performing some
complex calculation, and
when it's finished it sends
intent back to the activity and
it then updates the UI
accordingly.  Basic stuff, and
it's a reasonable approach, but
it does introduce some new
challenges.
Services are heavy-weight
components, right.  We don't
really want to create, then we
want to kill them as quickly as
possible to gain back some of
the system resources, and they
keep running even when your
activity isn't, which is kind of
the point but now you have to
keep in
mind your activity lifecycle,
what's it
doing, have you actually exited
the app, have you transitioned
to a new activity, should the
service keep running, should it
be canceled?  All of this stuff
you have to keep in mind and
it's doable but a lot of work to
get right.
Of course, because services are
part of the high priority it
prevents
the system from killing your app
if it needs to and there is no
guarantee the app will keep
running if the app is force
quit.
So there is another problem
in Android 0 you can't guarantee
your background services will be
running when you want them to.
You can't start a background
service when your app is in the
background from a broadcast
receiver and they'll be killed
after a few minutes after
they're initiated while the
activity was in the foreground.
Now, for really time
consuming things, which you need
to have run, this is still a
reasonable approach.  You have
an activity, it uses a service
to then download data from a
server, say, it's a nice time
consuming operation, and then
that saves it to a database and
then your activity just monitors
the database, so it's kind of a
one-way flow, which is nice.
There is a catch.  There is
always a catch.  And the catch
is that this is not an
efficient way to use the cell
radio, and
back in 20
2012, and I'm not going to go
into detail of how it work, when
you transition it stands in
standby andry do you says more
power and the goal is it reduces
latency for future transfers,
and that's all great, and the
reason it's important for us to
know, is if you're doing lots of
transfers you can keep the radio
turned on, it's going to draw
power more quickly.
So we have some specific advice
for
this, which was you should deal
with that.  You know how it
works now.
Efficiency is important so fix
it.  I had this whole metaphor
to help.  It was about cookie, I
have a friend who is an artist,
it was a excuse to get him to
draw things, and the idea here
was to use the big cookie model
where you're minimizing the
total number of transfers that
you're using across the app
lifecycle, so if you have
something that's not time
sensitive like
analytics, you Youku that up and
wait, and when there is an user
initiated refresh, you send the
queue and looking into the
future is there anything
scheduled to happen in a few
minutes and let's just do that
first, so it was a way to
manually batch and bundle all of
the transfers so they happen at
the same time and you get some
increased efficiency.
Now, as I'm sure you can
believe, doing all of this and
understanding how to do it right
was complicated in you
have that a room full of
engineers, much
like yourselves, back at
musconi, believe this is was a
legitimate equation you needed
to solve in order to figure out
how to do this right.  It's not.
This is just made up.
By 2012 we had a solution, a
solution which was the sync
adapter and the sync adapter we
claimed was pretty
straightforward.
Which is fair to say was a lie.
(laughter).
Now, it's still better than
doing it all yourself.  Once you
set it up, it's not that
complicated, right.  You're able
to trigger a one off for a
periodic transfer and a
syncadapter will handle all of
the background work, doing the
batching and time shifting for
multiple of your requests that
happen within a sort of time
window, so you don't have to
think about when you
trigger it, you just do and
trust the syncadapter to handle
the timing for you.
Unfortunately, to make this
all
work, you needed to have a
syncadapter, fair enough.
Syncadapter runs within its own
service.  Of course, you also
need to have an account manager,
which isn't used but
it's part of the API, and the
account authenticator also needs
its own service to run in.
Okay, I'm seeing a trend.  You
also need to have a content
provider, again, doesn't need to
be used but needs to exist.
You do all of this, write it all
in a
Java, and then maybe a dozen XMH
files you need to right and then
you're good to go, the
syncadapter works.  It's fair to
say that a lot of people trying
to make this work found it to be
kind of frustrating, and of
course it only batched and
bundled your transfers
within your own app, which is
why  2013,
great year Android 5 we
introduced the job scheduler API
which has now been replaced.
Job scheduler works at the
platform level and does the
batching and bundling for all of
the apps at the same time to be
able to take advantage, not just
of
cell radio battery improvement,
but all of the resource
improvements that we're
trying to do, things like
standby and dose mode and all of
this.
So within your app you
create a new job service that
does the asynchronous background
updates, in this case we're
using the asynctask which we can
use now because we don't have
the same memory leak problem,
and then within your specific
activity you just define the
criteria you need in order for
that job to be successfully
executed.  If it needs to be on
the Internet, it needs to be
charging, et cetera, how urgent,
what is the preferred timing, is
it periodic, all of that sort of
stuff.  The job scheduler will
then handle all of the
background work for you in the
most efficient way possible.
The only thing which would be
better than the job scheduler is
if it
worked in a backwards compatible
way,
which is way we launched Work
Manager, part of Jetpack.
To use Work Manager it works
basically the same way.  You
create a new worker and that is
where you're defining the
background work that needs to be
done, and then within your
activity you do the same thing
and you specify the constraints
that need to be met before this
work can be accomplished, and
then work manager will handle
all of this for you in the
background, same as job
scheduler, but
it now also encapsulates the
best practice solution for
earlier platform releases.  I
think it goes back to 4.4, so it
will use the latest and greatest
job scheduler if you're running
on the latest platform, all the
way back to probably alarm
manager for some of the earlier
platform releases.  Again, you
don't need to write any of that
boilerplate code for backwards
compatibility.  We do all of
that for you, so you don't have
to maintain it, find the bugs,
find the education, you can rely
on work manager to take care of
that, and of course this is
going to continue to improve in
future releases so as job
scheduler continues to improve
on the platform, work manager is
going to be able to evolve to
take advantage of some of those
changes.
You can learn all about
Work
Manager in Stage 2 today at
5:30.  I recommend going along.
It's really a cool new API.
So Work Manager, it's great if
it's something which is
genuinely time consuming and
needs to be initiated on the
client side.  Now, one of the
things which we've always said
and which really hasn't changed
is that wherever possible, you
should eliminate periodic
refreshes and
any updates that need to happen
based on changes of the service
side should be initiated by the
server, preferably
using Google Cloud Messaging, by
which
of course I mean Firebase
because GCM was depricated in
April.  Things move quickly.
Firebase Cloud Messaging
takes advantage of the same
scalable reliable GCM
infrastructure that we've been
using in the past, but also
improves delivery reporting and
reliability.  It also adds a web
console so you can send
notifications to your apps
without
having to have your own server
instance.
Now, the transfer this gives us
a pretty good solution, but
there is really no way this is a
viable solution for being able
to maintain a small amount of
data whenever the phone
rotates, and for that matter,
using  singlton ar overwriting
the application class, which I
may or may not said in previous
years, is similarly considered
somewhat distasteful.
So which is why in Android 3.
0, we introduced  headless
fragments and loaders.  I assume
everyone is familiar with these.
Fragments were designed to break
your UI up into chunks that were
independent, reusable, and
interchangeable.  The key here
was they were also aware of the
parent activity lifecycle.
Now, the trick with headless
fragments was that they didn't
have a UI, so you could
configure them to be
retained across an activity
restack based on a configuration
change and this was really nice
because it meant now we
have somewhere to store our data
model Indiana PendingIntent of
the activity being recreated
every time the configuration
changes.  (independent).
Managing fragments was
tricky.  If you attended the
first Android session here this
morning, you see just how tricky
it was.  You can add and remove
fragments from any activity,
have multiple instances of the
same fragment within the same
activity, the fragment
transactions are all done
asynchronously so you can't
guarantee when something is
there, and it's got its own
lifecycle to manage.
Now, none of this was
great.  Right.  You were able to
achieve what you wanted, but it
was complicated to make this all
work.
Now, loading, loading was
better.
Loading has made it easier to
asynchronously load data within
your fragments and activities,
and then you
can observe and react to changes
in the activity based on
whenever the underlying data
changed, and in most cases you
had to handle all of that
plumbing yourself, which meant
you  needed to load the data
from wherever it was stored, you
needed to then observe changes
within that underlying data and
bubble it back up through the
loader to have the simple code
in your activity.
Which was unless you used ku
curserloader, it did most of the
work for you.  You initial
liesed at creation time and then
you filled in a number of
callbacks to create a new curser
and then to receive the results
so that you can update the UI
accordingly.
Initial
Initiallyizeing the curserloader
-- you use the SQL statement
that you want to use to get back
your results and all of it gets
passed into a content resolver,
first your content provider and
gets you back a curser which you
can then use to update your UI.
But by definition that
meant that you needed to make
your data available
via a content provider, and
content providers are --
actually, you know what?  I'm
going to come back to content
providers, I'm going to leave it
in there for a moment.
So okay, so take a step back.
We've got headless fragments and
loaders and technically that
enables us to do everything we
need to do.  There is a problem
though, it's really hard to get
them to work together,
understand how to make them work
across multiple activities and
fragments in the various
different implementations of
both.  In fact, getting it all
to work reliably and well was,
again, it was frustrating.
Which is why we're all so
excited to see Android
architecture components.
Android architecture components
introduced viewmodels, livedata
and the room database.  It
practical replaces fragments and
loaders as a simple way to
separate your UI and your UI
data.
The viewmodel itself is really
simple to create.  You start
with a property that stores the
data that you want to expose, in
this case a mutable livedata
because livedata is cool, and
then you expose a method which
is going to return that
property, and so the first time
it's going to populate that
property and then from then on
it will return that cached
version.
Then you have a method which
does
that population, and again this
is done asynchronously.  In this
case again, we're using our old
friend the asynchronous task.
Then whenever the value of
your mutable livedata changes,
that is going to trigger any
observerses that you have
attached to it, so backing your
activity, all you need to do is
request
the viewmodels, ask for the
specific  viewmodel class that
you've just created, and then
call that viewmodels data access
method, which will either then
populate the data and return it,
but either way you add an
observer to that and then your
observed trigger is going to get
called both the first time you
attach the observer and then any
time the underlying livedata
changes.
Now, the beauty of viewmodels is
they survive activity restarts
so we don't have to deal with
that particular scenario, and
beauty of livedata is that it
understands the activity
lifecycle,
and so the first time the app is
run your viewmodel gets created,
populates
the livedata from the underlying
data
source, sends the results back
by the observed handler within
your activity, and then if
someone rotates their phone, the
activity gets  destroyed, gets
recreated, but the existing view
model is returned.  The existing
live data is returned via
the observe handler and it's
triggered with the latest
version of the data whether it's
updated or not in the interim.
In fact, livedata is really
smart
because it only sends updates
via the observe handler when the
activity is active because you
don't need to update the
activity if the UI isn't
actually
visible, and if there is new --
so if there is new data, it will
wait and transfer it once the
activity becomes active.
There is a total result and what
we do is feel less like this and
much more like this, which is
always our  goal.
Content providers, I promised
I'd come
back to don't providers, and
just some context.  This is what
happens, this is the number of
students enrolled in each of
the lessons of awr our Android
class, and the highlighted
columns when we get to providers
and loaders.  You get the
impression this is something
that is a little frustrating.
We improved it since then and
it's not so grim now.  And some
of what we're going to talk
about now actually explains some
of those improvements.
Why is it so frustrating?  This
is the boilerplate code for
creating a simple content
provider, I'm sure many of you
have built something like this.
In truth, it's really just the
first couple of methods.  It
goes on for a little while, and
keep in mind that this isn't
doing anything particularly
special.  It's just passing
content resolve
requests straight through to a
SQL-like database.  Obviously,
that's just the content provider
and then you need to create a
contract that defines the column
names that you want to use to be
able to interact with it, and
then of course you need to
create your own SQL at
openhelper which is how you
create, update, and access the
underlying database.
Now, all of there operates on
cursers which is probably not
what
you're using in your UI so
you'll need to create a class to
represent the records in the
database, which is nice.
It's actually quite simple in
kotlin,
but you also need code between
the
observes and add rows to the
tables and convert cursers and
lists of class objects.
Somewhere align the line you
need a list of observers so if
the database changes, your list
of objects also gets  updated.
It's a lot of code for something
which should be relatively
straightforward.
Quick one, there anyone here who
gets paid per line of code?
(laughter).
No.  Okay.  So if there is
and you were just too shy, that
old method actually works really
well, stick with  that.
For the rest of us, this is
where the room database really
comes into its own.
So it's part of an Android
Architecture components, now
part of Jetpack, and all you
need to do is start with the
class definition, defines the
columns that you want within
your class,
and you just add an annotation
to say this is an entity I want
to use in a database and this is
the primary key for this table.
Then you create a new room
database, which includes each of
the tables that you want to have
within that database and you
return an instance of the data
access object, and that is the
class where you specify all of
your database
interactions, inserts, updates,
and query, as many as you want
and as many different styles as
you want.
Now, you notice the queries here
return livedata and that's
really cool
because if you're storing your
UI data in the UI model
obviously you are because that's
the right way to do
things now, it simplifies the
viewmodel significantly.  You
request access to the room
databases access object, execute
the query, which returns
livedata itself and then you
just pass that livedata right
back through to any activity or
fragment which requests it.
Back in the activity, it works
the same way.  You've got the
same observe handler,
getting the same livedata
representing a collection of
objects, and you can use that to
update the UI whenever the
underlying database changes.
So you've got the same
outcome that you did before, but
10 times less boilerplate code,
10 times less code that you have
to maintain, and also if you
change a column name beforehand,
it was a lot of places that
could go wrong.  Now you just
modify the class.
Now, if you combine that with
the work manager, you actually
get a really
clean solution to this whole
process, right.
The work manager downloads data
from a server, updates the room
database accordingly, which then
sends the livedata to the
viewmodel within the activity
and fragment, all fragment you
want to use, which then by the
observe handler updates the UI.
So if you're not one of the
lucky folks still getting paid
by line of code, this is
probably a better solution,
right.
So speaking of better
solutions, what else have we
got?  I wanted to talk a little
bit about Android location
services because this is again a
topic that I've spent a lot of
time talking about.
Being able to find the current
position and put it on a map
somewhere is something that's
been part of Android since the
very first beta SDK.
So by 2011, I had actually
managed to amass quite a
selection of pro tips for how to
take advantage of the location
manager in the most efficient
and effective way possible.  It
was a big topic in a couple of
my
Android pro tip's talks.
So I went to the location
team and I said I've built a
project which encapsulates all
of our best practices, all of
the things which we tell people
to do, and it's fair to say that
they were impressed.  By which I
mean it really left an
impression.  They then went away
and did what they do which is
fixed everything, and so where
beforehand I had all of these
classes and interfaces, they
went away
and gave me an API as part of
the fused location provider,
which does all of the
magic for you, and encapsulates
all of those best practices
within a small number of simple
APIs.
All you need to do here is tell
it what's more important,
battery life or accuracy?  How
often do you want to get
results, and the fuse location
provider goes and does all of
the hard work for you.
Now that said, things have
changed a little bit n. our area
we made some changes, new
restrictions about how you can
receive
location updates while the app
is in the background in order to
save battery life.
Specifically, that means if
you're in the background you
only receive updates
from location manager or a few
times an hour.  A few ways to
deal with it, make a foreground
service, another approach is
to use geofence, so for those of
you who remember the very first
version of geofencing on Android
were proximity alerts and
proximity alerts were  bad.
Easy enough to set up and
specify a
lat, long radius around a point
and they would reliably figure
if you went across the boundary.
The thing the way it achieved it
is by
turning turning on and leaving
on your
GPS, if you had a proximity
alerm set GPS would run
constantly, it's not what the
documentation said but it is
what happens.
Now the fused location
provider also gave us a real
geofencing API that had all the
functionality that was claimed
from -- that was claimed to be
done with proximity alerts but
also gave
you a few additional
improvements.  Most important of
which is that it didn't keep the
GPS  locked permanently on.
We it take
our geoto the next level which
allows us to make more
complicated fences, we can add
date and time, proximity to
beacon, user activity, walking,
cycling, driving, and device
state.  You can combine all of
these conditions together, such
as in this example, we have one
fence which is triggered if you
drive within 1,000 meters of a
given location between 10 and 6.
We have a little bit of
time left.  One thing I  learned
in 2018 is that there is a new
way to -- I'm sorry.  That
should be there is a new way to
control media.  Right.
Now, back in the day,
controlling media playback was
done with the media player.  I'm
going to buzz through this
pretty quickly.  Mainly it meant
that you had to listen to media
buttons getting clicked.  Now,
of course, you can control media
a bunch of different ways so we
have a
better solution which is
exoplayer that effectively
replaces the framework, media
player is easy to customize and
extend.  I'm not going to go
through the detailts, but I had
been speaking so slowly, so I
recommend you go to Mark and
Andrew's talk tomorrow morning
at 10:30 and get all of the
details.
Now, not all of the changes
in Android have been in code.
Some of the biggest changes are
actually in the  availability of
Android expertise.  Back when we
started we didn't have soip
slack or Google developer
experts or stack overflew.
We had IRC, Google developer
groups, Dev rel people that
spoke at conference, and that
still kind of happens.
The big change now is that we're
just voices within a much larger
developer ecosystem.  There are
now lots and lots of people
around the world who help each
other.
This is just a small selection
of the
90 Googler experts  specialing
in kotlin around the world, a
small selection of the
engineering team that we have
helping the community.
Similarly we have Android
conferences all around the
world.  This is a small
selection of some of the Android
events that people pointed out
to me on Twitter a couple of
weeks ago when I asked what the
best conferences to go to were
because really the biggest tip
that I can give you is that much
more than changes in the tooling
or the frameworks or the APIs or
Jetpack or anything else, much
more than that the biggest thing
driving Android development
forward is the community, it's
the people around you, the
people online who are all
helping each other
with Android, and it's important
because we know the up with
thing that doesn't change is
that things are going to change.
So take advantage of things like
Jetpack to make things simpler,
work with the people around you,
and hopefully your apps will
survive much longer than my pro
tips.  Thank you.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.
Grand
Ambassadors will assist with
directing you through the exits.
We'll be making room for people
in the next session.  If you
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
May 9, 2018
11:30 a.m.
PT
What's New in
Architecture Components
>> Welcome to Google I/O
2018.  We're happy you're
joining us as we celebrate
platform innovations at Google.
Right now you checked into
registration to receive your
badge.
It must be visibly warn at all
times,
and don't forget you need it to
ride the shuttles and enter the
end of the day activities on
days one and two.  Throughout
the event visit Google.com/I/O.
Or download the app for the most
up-to-date schedules and
conference map.  For  questions
or assistance stop by the
information desk  located across
from the Codelabs building or
chat with any staff member
wearing a yellow badge.
Sessions will take place in the
aphitheatere as well as eight
stages throughout the venue.
If you haven't received a seat
for your favorite session, or if
you miss a session, don't worry
recordings will be available
shortly after the sessions end.
Be sure to visit the Codelabs
with  red-to-code kiosks and
Google staff will be available
for helpful advice and provide
direction if you need support
Make some time to visit the
office hours and app  reviews
tent to meet one-on-one with
Googlers and ask your technical
questions and get feedback on
your ploj projects.  If you're
looking to network join one of
the several  meetups hosted in
the community lounge.  Finally,
we would like to invite to you
visit the sandbox domes where
you can explore, learn, and play
with our latest products and
platforms, interactive demo,
physical installations, and
more.  After sessions are done
for the day, stick around for
food, drinks, music, and fun.
Be prepared for some surprises
along the way.  We'd like to
take this opportunity to remind
you that we are dedicated to
providing an inclusive event
experience for everyone, and
that by attending
Google I/O you agree to our Code
of  Conduct posted throughout
the venue
Your opinion is valuable to
us.  After the event, look out
for a feedback form to share
your experience.  Thanks for
attending and have a wonderful
time exploring Google I/O.
May 9, 2018
11:30 a.m. PT
What's New in Architecture
Components
>> Good morning.
(Applause)
>> LUKAS BERGSTROM: It's
great to see everybody here.
I'm Lukas berg strom.  Product
manager.
How many were here last year
when we addressed architecture
components for the first time.
Awesome.  This is a much bigger
venue so that's actually a
descent percentage.  When we did
launch architecture components
last year we were doing
something sort of different for
us.  For the first time we were
offering
explicit guidance in how to
architect your app and giving
you components letting you do
that.
And frankly for us, it was a
little
bit of a journey into the
unknown, so 1 12 months in let's
check in on how we're doing.
We've shipped 26 releases since
May of last year, so we've been
constantly iterating and
improving the core set of
architecture components.  The
sign of any healthy Open Source
project, we have a very active
issue tracker and I'd like to
thank everybody that's taken
time to file a feature
request or even a bug and we've
closed a lot of those.
We launched a major new library
Paging, which is now stable and
we'll talk a little bit more
about it today.  And I'm pleased
to say based on our survey data,
over half of you are using or
planning to use architecture
components, and this survey was
done
only a few months after we went
stable, so this data is pretty
out of date by now, but I'm
pretty proud of the fact that
only a few months after
launching
to stable, over half of the
Android developers we talked to
were planning to use this stuff.
But more importantly than any of
this, you've told us that
architecture components actually
make it easier for you to build
robust apps, that having a clear
path on how to architect your
app and components that help you
realize that has actually made a
difference in the real world in
how you build your apps.  And
we've heard that not just once
but we've heard that over and
over from a lot of developers
that have taken time to speak to
us.
So architecture components has
grown and we're going to
continue to invest here.
This is foundational, we  think,
for Android apps going forward.
But not just are we investing in
architecture components but this
year with Jetpack, we're going
to take that same approach that
we took with Architecture
Components, a blank sheet
of paper approach to how Android
developer experience should be
and how we can improve things
for you.  Jetpack is going to
take that and apply that to the
rest of the developer
API service that we offer.
So now I'm going to turn it over
to Yigit to talk about what's
new in Architecture Components.
(Applause).
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Thanks, Lukas.
So we'll talk about what we've
been doing in the last one year.
We'll look at exiting libraries,
talk about improvement, and also
look at the
new shiny stuff, paging,
navigation, and work manager.
Let's start with
lifecycles, so we
have shipped  lifecycles in the
last I/O but to better
understand why we have
created this component, let's go
to two years before.  In 2016,
we did a bunch of surveys and
asked developers, what is the
hardest part of the Android
development?
And by far in the list, big
surprise,
was lifecycle  managements.  We
were wondering what can be hard
about a phone rotating or users
reaching applications, this
appears all the time on Android,
Android is built for this.  But
if you look at the problem in
detail, if you want to handle
them properly in your
application, you need
to understand these graphs very
well and when these two are
interlinked it becomes very
confusing, so we we have
created lifecycles component to
get at these problems, and it
seems to be
working because many developers,
you ask
testimonials, a group of
problems just disappeared from
their application when is they
started using these libraries.
Another important change of
lifecycles is one year ago we
introduced them as a optional
library, but now they're a
fundamental part of Android
development.  You don't need to
do any additional libraries to
start using them.
Now both app
compatactivity and both include
lifecycle.
Another interesting thing that
happens is the community
adoption, so we ourself create
new APIs that  works with
lifecycles but we do other
people doing the same in their
libraries and this is
so much easier because already
app compat has the dependencies
so you can easily depend on them
in your libraries.
One great example is auto
dispose library from Uber, so if
you're using Java but you want
the automatic
lifecycle planning management,
you can
just add this to the stream,
give it to lifecycle and it will
manage the subscription for you
for free.
Now, working on these things
we've also covered more problems
we have.
One of them is the fragments of
lifecycle.  Now fragments has a
very complicated lifecycle.
Let's look at an example.  So if
you have a fragment that when
it's created observing the
livedata.  It goes through the
creation, we create a view for
it, and it goes to the resume
state.
At this point if you're losing
your  livedata, the UI will
start displaying them and
everything works fine.  Later on
the user hits a button, so you
want to detect this fragment
because they're going to another
fragment, and you're going to
stop that fragment but once the
fragment is stopped, we don't
need the view for it.  We would
like to reclaim those resource,
so we destroy the view.
Later on user hits the back
button,
you go back to the previous
button, you reattach, and
because we have destroyed the
wheel we create a new one, we go
ahead and do it but it's a brand
new wheel, and it goes through
the regular
creation cycle and now we have a
bar.  This new wheel will never
resume the state of that live
data because you're using the
fragments lifecycle to observe
it so we don't have any reason
to redispatch the same value.
Of course, if livedata
receives any value, the UI will
be updated but it's kind of too
late because on recreate your UI
has a bad state.
Now, this left you with two
options, you either subscribe
oncreate, it looks very clean
and one-time setup, but it will
fail if you recreate the wheel
so you need to manually recreate
the wheel.
And onconcreteview handles the
recreation but you have double
registrations you need to use
and lose automatic lifecycle
managements.
So the problem here is
fragments have not one but two
lifecycles and we
have decided to embrace it and
give the fragment view its own
lifecycle.
So now starting a separate
library 28 or Android  text, 1.
2, while observing livedata you
can specify the viewlifecycle,
so while you're observing if
it's about the wheel, you use
the wheel lifecycle, otherwise
you use the fragment lifecycle
and we manage the subscription
for you for free.
Okay.  Data binding, so when we
started to look at our offerings
as part of Jetpack
we decided to move data binding
as part of architecture
competence.
If you're not already using data
binding it's our solution for
boilerplate UIs.  If you have
this like this in your
application, binding layouts you
can reference your object and we
take care of updating the UI for
you.
In data binding 3.
1 we have added native support
for livedata.
So if you have a view for live
user
and pass for binding, you can
use the livedata as regular
field,  databinding will
understand it's live data and
generate the correct codes.
Unfortunately this is not
enough for it to observe it
because data binding doesn't
have a lifecycle.  To fix that
when you get your binding
instance, you just tell it which
lifecycle it should use and it
will start observing the live
data, keep itself up to date,
you don't need to write any code
for this.
We have also part of the data
binding compiler to be more
incremental.
If you have a project with
multiple modules it's going to
compile a lot faster, and we're
also working on making the
compilation more incremental but
they're not finished yet.
This new compiler also gave us
the ability to support instant
apps and now you can use data
binding in the future modules of
your instant tabs.
Okay.
Room, my favorite architecture
competence.  So  Room was our
solution for object
mapping that binds the gap
between the SQLete or Java code.
One important change in  Room 1.
1 is the support for better
multithreading.  So if you are
using Room 1.0 and if you have
one thread trying to
exsetter exert a lot of database
into the database and another
thread trying to read the data,
while your write is  executing
your read will be blocked and it
can only execute after the write
is complete.
In Room 1.
1 they can run in parallel, and
another
nice feature of this is your
writes run
a lot faster than before.  Best
part of this change, you don't
need to do anything for take
advantage of this.
If the device is running, Jelly
Bean or influencer and not a
low-memory device we're going to
enable it for free.
Okay.
Another important addition to
Room was
the support for @RawQuery, but
to understand why we needed
@RawQuery let's talk about the
query annotation.
While using Room you can specify
and use the main parameters and
put as regular function elements
and tell the Room what to
return.  The best part of this
setup is that Room is going to
validate all of the set compiled
time so if there is a mistake in
your query, if your parameters
doesn't measure, what you try to
return doesn't make sense, it's
going to file the compilation
and let you know whether a is
wrong.
Now, this is all cool
except what
if you don't know the query at
compiled time?  What if you're
writing a real estate
application, my user can't
search houses with the price,
maybe they want to specify
number of bedrooms,  bathroom,
whether it has a yard.  If you
needed a query and it mattered
for each variation of this that
would be impossible to maintain.
So what you do in this case is
you
create at runtime with the
options provided for the user
and you provide the arguments
for that query.  You obtain a
instance of the  Room
database and use this query
method to get the result.
So far so good.
The problem with this approach
is that it returns a curser.
Who wants a curser in you're
trying to get the list of
houses, so this looks
like a failure of the library,
hence we decided to introduce
@RawQuery.  It looks very
similar to Query, except instead
of specifying the query in the
annotation, you pass it as a
parameter to the function and
then you tell us what you want
us to return.
Now here Room cannot validate
the query anymore so it's kind
of like you promise us to send
the right query and it will take
care of it.  Once you have that,
if you go back to our previous
example, we can get an
instance of our Dao, and we need
to merger with parameters and
the query in
the simple of the which is a
basic data
holder and then you compress it
to the Dao and get the list of
houses, no more cursers and no
more boilerplate code.
Okay.  Paging, so Paging is our
solution for
lazy loading in RecyclerView,
but to better understand why we
drew up this competence, I want
to go to an example.
So you have a list like this,
it's very common and every
single application
has it, user can scroll, but you
know it
takes a much larger list than
what's on the screen.
If you're in a application, it
could be a very, very long list
so you probably cannot use the
memory and very inefficient to
load all of it, so what you
would do is keep some of it in
memory, the rest of it in
database, and you also have your
server competent where you pull
this data from.
This is actually hard to
implement properly, and that's
why we have created
the Paging library to make this
common flow very easily and
efficient to implement.
Paging library comes with a
paged
list, an actual Java list
implementation but it works with
a data source.  Every time you
access the items in the
page list it pulls data from the
data
source lazily, it just brings in
more data.
How can we get an instance of
these?  It's actually super easy
if you're using Room.  So Room
knows thousand create the data
source, so it's a great example
of how the architecture
components work very well
together.  You can just tell
Room to return your data source
or a data source factory, and in
this case I'm using a data
source factory because data is
something that changes and each
data source represents a
snapshot so we need a factory so
that
we can create new data sources
when data changes.
Once you have this you can use
the
live page builder and build on
it, it's going to give you a
livedata paged list of users and
almost the same as livedata list
of  users.
Now in your activity or
fragment, you would use this
page list adapter which is a
cycle review adapter that  works
with page list.  You would
observe the line data any time
we have a new page list, give it
to
the adapter, and then the
adapter can just call this and
getitem function typed in the
user object.  It's a super
simple code to write and we take
care of all the hard work of
paging it lazily for you.
Even though I have shown
all of those examples with
livedata, paging
supports Rxjava out of the box,
if you
are using that and you want a
level of pages, you can just get
the same factory that the room
generates and but instead
use the RxPageed Builder to
build.
Paging features from the
database have been shown here
but also it supports paging from
the network or you can combine
both database and the network
for the best user experience.
To learn more about it, please
join tomorrow at 2:30 in the
Paging session.
All right.
Now --
>> LUKAS BERGSTROM:
Possibly some of the expense of
what Fu is gone new but when you
think about sort of core
problems that almost every app
has to deal with, in-app
navigation has to be close to
the top of the list there.
Right now the framework
doesn't
really offer anything for you to
do -- anything for you to use
there other than
start activity, which for
various reasons is not the best
option.
So that means that for
navigation there are a bunch of
things that you have to figure
out on your own, and that
ranges from executing a fragment
transaction without  throwing an
exception, hopefully, passing
arguments
from place to place, possibly
even with type safety if you can
figure that out.  Testing the
navigation is working and that
the right things are happening
when
you navigate from place to
place, making sure the up and
back buttons work correctly and
take the user where
they're supposed to go, mapping
deep links to destinations in
your app and having that work,
and by the time you've solved
all of these problems, you've
typically gone one of two
directions, you've either
written 60% of a navigation
framework just for your app
or you've got a lot of
errorprone boilerplate and so
everywhere navigation needs to
happen you have a bunch of
parallel lines of code that need
to be changed, and any time the
navigational structure or the
app changes, and this is all
pretty brittle and can end up
being a headache.
Individually these problems are
pretty tractable but when you
compose them into a realworld
example, so say I have a item
screen in my app, maybe a
product screen, and that screen
is
accessible via Deeplink, but
actually there are other pages
that, you know, if the user had
navigated here by opening the
app from the home screen, they
would
have come via the home screen,
the category screen, and I want
the up but the button to take
them through the screens rather
than exiting the app, right.
That means if somebody
deeplinks into the app, I need
to synthesize these screens and
add them to the back stack but
only on a deeplink, and talking
to a third party developer, he
said, you know, it's when you're
in the middle of writing code to
do this, you know, on any
deeplink into my app and
synthesize
the back stack correctly, you
start to feel maybe this is a
failure of the framework, so
that's why we're really
happy to be launching Navigation
which
is a, both a runtime component
that performs navigation for you
and a visual
tool that works with XML to
define the navigational
structure of your app and then,
you know, allows you to just
navigate at  runtime with a
single navigate call.
And so the kinds of things that
you're going to get for free,
right, that you simply need to
define an XML and then the
navigation framework will
handle it runtime for you, are
animations, passing arguments in
a type safe way from place to
place, making
sure that up and back work
correctly, and mapping deep
links to various screens in your
app.  And last but not least, no
more fragment transaction ever.
(Applause).
So I'll show a couple of demos
of this in action.
The first one is just to kind of
give you an idea of what this
all is, so we're looking at a
set of fragment destinations in
my app, and I'm adding a new
one, and now I'm creating an
action and this action is the
thing that I'm actually going to
call at runtime to go
from place to place.
You can see that there are
a bunch of other options that
we'll get into more in the
navigation talk, but the one
thing I do quantity to show you
in more
detail right now is the example
we went through before.  So this
is a simplified version of that
where there isn't a category
screen, we just have the home
screen and
then the item screen, but I'm
going to
right now configure this to both
have a deep link pointing at the
item screen and make sure that
if somebody deep links into the
app that they go to the
home screen first when they hit
Up or Back rather than just
exiting the app right away.
So first I'm just going to
configure a deep link on this
screen, and the curly brackets
that I'm going to
put around Item ID indicate that
I want to extract a variable
there and pass it as an argument
into the item screen.  Okay.
Now that's ready to go.  If I
compile and run my  app, that
will just work and navigate to
the right destination.
Now I just set the home screen
to the start destination, and
that means that it's the
hierarchical parent of all the
other screens in the graph, so
when someone deep links into the
item screen and then hits Up,
they're going to go
directly to that home screen, so
now I've just solved in 30
seconds what would have been a
really terrible and
time consuming task in Java or
Kotlin back in the old world.
So now I'm going to pass it
eefer
off to Yigit to talk about Work
Manager.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: After using
demos
for the past couple weeks it
feels like magic, I hope you all
like it.
Work Manager is our example of
deferrable guaranteed execution.
Whether a do I mean by this?
You're out of executions on
Android that you really, really
want to do if user does
something.  If user tries to
send a tweet, you want to send
it now, but if there is no
network connection you want to
send it as soon as device is
connected to the Internet.
There are things like uploading
logs you may want to do if the
device is charging or you may
want to periodically sync your
data with your backup.  Now, we
know this is not a new problem
on Android.  We had some
solutions for this.
We have introduced Job Scheduler
in
Lollipop and the functionality
into devices that has Google
Play Services
and we also have manager for
exact timing.  And now each of
these has different behaviors
and different APIs, it becomes
very hard to implement.  Hence
we have built Work Manager that
sits on top of them and provides
them
much cleaner API with new
functionalities.  Work  Manager
has two simple concepts, you
have the workers that execute
these
actions and you have the work
requests which trigger these
workers.
Now, if you want to look at
the sample worker, this is
basically all you do.
Your worker clause, you
implement one function that says
do the work, and that function
just needs to return us what
happened as a result of that
work, so you can do whatever you
do and you return the result.
There is no services, no
intents, no bundles, nothing
like that.
Once we have the worker, we
need to
create a work request so you can
use this one-time work builder
or there is a periodic version
of this one and you can specify
the worker clause.
But now you can also
constraints.  You can tell it if
there is network
connection, if the device is
charnging,
or back off criteria, so if the
work is failing, how should we
retry it, you can also pass
input parameters to these
workers.  Once you build that
work request, you
can get an instance of work
manager and
enque it and now work manager
will take care of executing it.
One of the important
distinctions
of Work Manager is it has input
and output semantics so the
workers can receive input but
they can also output some data.
You can obvious this data
through Work Manager, but it's
actually very useful to train
your workers.
So imagine you have an
application where a user picks
an image from their device and
you want to route some image
processing on that picture, and
then once it's done you want to
upload it to your server.  Now,
these are two different units of
work.  Like you can process the
image, maybe you want to do it
when the device is idol or you
can do it any time, but to
upload it to server you need
Internet connection, but you
don't want to wait the
processing for the Internet
connection because it doesn't
need it.
This is super easy to implement
in Work Manager.  So have two
different workers, they'll have
single functionality, one of
them does the image processing
and the other one does the
upload to server.  Okay, the
helper function that receives an
image file and creates the
process image work request,
prepares the input, uses the
same builder to produce the
request.
Now we get that and we want our
network upload to wait for the
Internet
connection, so we set a con
constraint, and we say wait for
Internet connection before
trying to run this work request,
and then create the
upload image work using that
constraint.
Once we have them you can tell
work manager and say okay, begin
with the process image work, and
once you're done then run the
upload to server work, and
in you enqueue both of these as
a automatic operation to the
Work Manager.  And your device
start and anything can happen in
between, and we will take care
of running the two.
You can also use this API
extensively and run image
processing in parallel the same
way, so if user picks multiple
photos and you want to process
all of them but upload it to
server while some of them are
done, can you easily do that
with Work Manager.
We'll just use the save
function, create three work
requests for each of the images
the user picked, we create the
upload work image in the same
way we
did before, and now we say okay,
begin with all of these three
work items and once all of them
are done then upload
work and then you enqueue that
as automatic operation and that
takes care of running it.
Another important future of
Work
Manager is it's not just for job
scheduler, (?), it's executed
itself.  So this is why
opportunistic execution is
important.
So if you have an application
the user can send an email and
they hit a send
button, you send the job info to
the job scheduler or Firebase
and it will eventually call you
to execute it back.
The problem here is that I don't
know how long it will take.
Even if your device currently
has network connection it may
take only a couple of minutes
for job scheduler to call you
back and you have no control
over it, you just don't know.
And it results in a bad user
experience to work around that,
and what you usually do is you
also have your own thread pool
whenever user hits send, you try
to run the same thing there as
well, and you take care of the
duplicating when the job
scheduling calls you back.
If you are using Work
Manager you don't need to think
about it.  Because when you send
the work request for the  Work
Manager it puts it into its own
database.  It tells job
scheduler or whichever scheduler
it has on the device, okay, I
need to be invoked when these
constraints are met, but it also
checks
those constraints itself.
If they are ready it will
instantly execute the job.
Laitser on if job sceld iewler
asks to execute, Work Manager
knows whether it executed or not
and handles the request
properly.  To learn more about
Work Manager please join us
today at 5:30 in the  Work
Manager session.
>> LUKAS BERGSTROM: All right.
What's next?  Okay.  So I think
it's been a pretty great year in
Android App  Development.
Hopefully you agree.  We
launched a set of great new
components last year and we kept
working on those and iterating
on those.  We've launched three
new major
components, Work Manager,
Navigation, and Paging since
then.  So does that mean we're
done?  Obviously, not.  We have
a lot more to do an the first
thing we want to do is make
Architecture Components the
default way that people build
Android apps and that doesn't
mean
that it's going to be required,
by but it does mean that we want
to make sure that as many people
as possible get Architecture
Components regardless of how
they get into Android
development, so that means not
only are we going to be building
more tools like the
Navigation Editor in Android
Studio that are sort of
Architecture Components aware,
but we'll also be adding more
templates that include things
like ViewModels so that people
starting a new
project have the easiest
possible  onramp into Android
development.
In terms of libraries, not
only are we going to be building
more architecture components and
not only are we going to be
building in more of the kind of
core architecture components
goodness like lifecycle
awareness into
Jetpack, but we want to look at
other Google APIs as well and
see, you know,
how we can make those sort of a
architecture components a ware
where if you call another Google
API that's asynchronous it
already has that built
in, you're getting architecture
components whether you know
you're using it or not.
Finally, we've heard from
everybody that you want us to
speak with a single voice, you
want us to give clear and
consistent guidance, so that
means that in terms of
education, and that means not
just documentation, but it also
means sample apps, Codelabs,
that all of
this stuff is going to be
refract
refactored to built on a tech
xur components so whether you
start with guide app
architecture or download a
simple media player app and
start customizing it, that you
kind of
regardless of when you're onramp
in Android  development is, that
we get to you the best possible
place.
We know that we still have some
areas left to address in the
core and
you can see some of those here,
so this is just to say we're
definitely not going to stop
investing in the original set of
architecture components, and
there is some not just
problem-solving here but some
exciting stuff that we can
do around how to make
architecture
components as fun for people to
use for people using Kotlin.
There is a lot to be done and
still I think the core set of
app architecture and lifecycle
problem areas, so we'll keep
working there.
But beyond that I think
you'll see something interesting
about your
trajectory if we look at all the
components we've launched to
date.  Last year this kind of
set of architecture components
was, these are relatively small
pieces, relatively small APIs
that are designed to be used in
a lot of different places in
your
app, and then if you look at
room
navigation, work manager, these
are much larger and richer APIs
but they're still
sort of relatively sort of
self-contained.  They solve a
single problem and do it really
well.
Paging also solves a single
problem and solves it well, but
in this case we took a very
specific use case, right, so
lazy loading for recyclerview,
and we're actually in this case
orchestrating multiple
architecture components and
pieces of Jetpack to solve that
problem, so Paging is a little
bit higher level, and it's not
just sort of here is your object
mapping layer, right, it
actually
takes a very specific, I know I
have or recycling view with more
data that I can fit in memory,
and it uses multiple pieces of
architecture components to make
that as easy as possible.
And we want to continue to, you
know, build more stuff like that
so not just -- we're not just
going to keep investing in the
core areas of app architecture
and lifecycle, but we want to
start solving higher-level
problems and make more and more
as easy as possible.
But I can't leave today
without thanking everybody that
helped us get here.  The reason
that we were able to have a
really high quality bar for
architecture components was
because a lot of people, many of
whom are here today, were
reallying generous with their
time and that includes not just
filing issues on the issue
tracker but also, you know,
testing pre-release components,
having
one-on-one conversations with us
to tell us what your biggest
problem areas with Android app
development were.  This has been
critical to us in making
sure that we're kind of focusing
on the right problems and
delivering solutions that are
going to work for you, so I
really have to thank everybody
in the community that's been so
helpful.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Thank you.
(Applause).
>> LUKAS BERGSTROM: And
there is a lot more.  We had to
fly over a lot of don't today,
but you'll be able to go into a
lot more depth in the talks on
Navigation, Work  Manager, and
Paging.  So thanks a lot, and I
hope to see you there.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Thank you.
(Applause).
May 9, 2018
12:30 p.m. PT
TensorFlowT
TensorFlow for JavaScript
lts
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
(Applause)
>> Hi, everyone. Thanks
for coming today to see our
talk.  My name is Daniel
>> NIKHIL THORAT: My name
is Nikhil,.
>> NICK KREEGER: And I'm
Nick.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: Today
we're very happy to talk about
JavaScript.  If you're in the
world of Machine Learning, doing
a training model or anything
about Machine Learning, you're
most certainly dealing with
piet
Python, it's been one of the
mainstream for the last decade.
It has a lot of tools.  It
doesn't have to be that way.
Today we're here to convince you
that the browser and JavaScript
have a lot to offer to the world
of Machine Learning, and
TensorFlow Playground is a great
example of that.  How many
people here have seen this
visualization?  Quite a few.
I'm glad.
For those of you that
haven't seen
it, TensorFlow  Playground is
in-browser neural network
visualization and shows
you what is happening inside the
neuralnetwork as the network is
training.  When we released
this, this was kind of a fun
small project, and when we
released this it had tremendous
success, especially in the
educational domain, and even
today we get emails from high
schools and universities around
the world thanking us for
building this and they're using
it to teach students, beginners
about Machine Learning.
When we saw the success of
TensorFlow Playground we started
wondering, why is it so
successful?  We think the
browser and JavaScript have a
lot to do with it.  For one
thing that's very special
about the browser, it has no
drivers and no installations.
You can share your app with
anyone and all they have to do
is click on a link and see your
application.
Another important thing about
the browser is it's highly
interactive.  In the playground
app, we have all
these controls, drop-down
controls that you can change and
quickly run different
experiments.
Another nice thing about the
browser is it runs on laptops,
it runs on mobile devices, and
these devices have sensors like
the microphone and the
camera and the accelorometer and
they're all behind standardized
web APIs that you can easily
access in your web app.  We
didn't take advantage of this in
the playground, but we'll show
you some demos later.
Most importantly, when
you're
building web apps, these apps
run client
side which makes it easy to have
the data stay on the client and
never have to send it back to a
server.  You can do processing
on device, and this is important
for privacy.
Now to come back to the play
playground example, the library
that
powers the visualization is not
TensorFlow.
It's a small necker
necker
small neuralnetwork and it
became clear when this was so
successful and popular that we
should go on and build such a
library, and we went and built
deeplearn.js that was released
in August of 2017.  We figured
out a way how to make it
fast and scale by utilizing the
GPU of
laptops and cell phones through
WebGL.  For those of you that
are not familiar, WebGL is a
technology
originally meant for  rendering
3-D graphics, and the library
that we built  allows for both
inference and training entirely
in the browser.
When we released deeplearn.
js we had an incredible
momentum.  The community went
instantly with it
and took pre-trained models from
Python and put it in the
browser.  One example I want to
show you of that is the style
transfer demo.  Someone went and
took the pre-trained model and
this demo has a image, a source
image on the left and an artist
on the right, and then it can
mash them together and they made
this in a creative, interesting
application.
Another demo is people will take
models that read a lot of text
and then they can generate new
sentences and then they port it
in the browser and explore the
novel interface, how you can
explore all the different
endings of a sentence.
In the educational domain,
people
took the standard convolutional
neuralnets and built a fun
little game where you can train
your own image recognition model
just by using the webcam and
this was very popular.
And lastly, researchers took
another example, they took a
font
generation model that can
generate new fonts, previously
was trained on a lot of font
styles, and then they built at
that novel interface in the
browser, highly interactive,
where you can explore different
types of  fonts.
Now building on that incredible
momentum we have with deeplearn.
js about a month ago at the
TensorFlow dev  summit, we
announced we're joining
the TensorFlow family and with
that we introduced a new
ecosystem of tools and libraries
aren't JavaScript and Machine
Learning called TensorFlow.js.
Now before we dive into the
detailts, I want to go over
three main use cases of what you
can do with TensorFlow.js today.
You can write models directly in
the browser.  We have sets of
APIs for that.
You can also take pretrained
models that were trained in
Python or other languages and
then port them for inference in
the browser.  You can also take
these existing
pretrained models and retrain
them, do transfer learning right
there on device.
To give you a schematic view of
the library, we have the browser
that does all the computation
using WebGL.  TensorFlow.js has
two sets of APIs that sit on top
of this, a core API which gives
you a
low-level building blocks,
linear
algebra operations like multiply
and
add, and on top of it we have
layers API which gives you
high-level building
blocks and best practices to
build neuralnets.
And on top of that because there
are so many models written in
Python today, we offer tools to
take an
existing model, a
keras model and these tools will
convert that model to run in the
browser.
Now, to give you an example
of our core API, I'm going to
show you how we're going to go
over code that  tries to train a
model that fits a polynomial
curve and we have to learn the
three coefficients, A, B, and C.
Now this example is pretty
simple, but the code walks you
through all the steps of how you
would train such a model, and
these steps generalize across
different models.
So we import TensorFlow for
TensorFlow/TensorFlow.js, and
for those of you not familiar
this is standard EF6 modern
JavaScript.  We have our three
variables that we're trying to
learn, A, B, and C.  We mark
them as variables which means
that the optimizer of the
machine, it's
machinery that runs and trains
our neuralnetwork can change the
variables for us.
We have our function, F of X,
given some data it will compute
the output and
this is just a polynomial
function, quadratic function.
On top of the standard API like
tf add and tf multiply.
We have a chaining, and that's
been
popular in the world, you can
call these mathematical methods
on it itself and this reads
better closer to how we read
math.
That's our model.  To train
it we need a last function and
in this case we're just
measuring the distance between
the prediction of
the model and the label, the
ground truth data.  We need an
optimizer, and this is the
machinery that can optimize and
find
those coefficients, we specify a
learning grade there, and for
some
number of  epochs passes over
your data we call optimizer.
minimize with our loss and f of
X and Ys.
So that's our model.
Now, this is clearly notes how
everyone writes Machine Learning
models today.  Over the years we
have developed best practices
and high-level building blocks
and new APIs amerged like TF
Layers and  Keras that makes it
much easier to write these
models, and for that I want to
walk over our Layers API to show
you how easy it is.
We're going to go through a
simple neuralnetwork that sums
two numbers, but what's special
about this network is
that the input comes as a string
character by character, so 09 +
10 is
the input to this network being
fed as a string and the network
has an internal memory where it
encodes this information, it has
to save it, and then
on the other end the neural
network has to output the sum,
100, again character by
character.
Now, you might wonder why go
through such a trouble to train
this neural network like this,
but this example forms the basis
of modern machine translation
and that's why we're going over
this.
To show you the code, we import
TensorFlow from TensorFlow.
js and we have our model and we
say  tf.sequential which means
it's just a linear stack of
layers.  The first two layers
I'm not going to go into
details, but those two are
building blocks that can take
the
strings into a memory, into an
internal presentation.
And the last three layerses take
this internal presentation and
turn it into numbers, and that's
our model.
To train it we need to compile
it
with a loss and optimizer, and
metric we
want to monitor we call accuracy
and we call model.fit with our
data.  One thing I want to point
out with model.fit, training can
take for this example, it can
take 30 or 40 seconds in the
browser, and while that's
running we don't want to blog
the main UI thread.  We want our
app to be responsive, so this is
why model.
fit is an asynchronous call and
we get a callback once it's done
with the history object which
has our accuracy as it evolved
over time.
Now, I went through examples of
how
you write these models in the
browser, but there is also a lot
of models that
have already been written in
Python and
for that we have tools that
allow you to import them
automatically.
Before we dive into the
details, I
want to go through and show you
a fun little game that our
friends at Google
brand studio built called emoji
scavenger hunt and it takes
advantage of
a pretrained model convolutional
neural network that can detect
400 items.
I'm going to walk over to a
pixel
phone and open up a browser just
to show you the TensorFlow.js
can also run in a browser
because we're using standard
WebGL.
And I'm going to ask here,
Nikhil on my right, to help me
out here because I'm going to
need some help.  To give you
some little details about the
game, it shows you an emoji, and
then you have to go with your
camera, run around your house
and find the real
version item of that emoji
before time
runs out and there is a neural
network that has to detect that.
All right.  Shall we start?  Let
me see.  We're going to play it
here live.  All right.  We have
to find a watch, 20 seconds.
>> NIKHIL THORAT: A watch.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: That's
great.  Woo hoo!  All right.
Let me see what's next.
We need a shoe.
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Shoe.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: Thanks,
buddy.  Yay!  Let's see what the
next item is.  Banana.  We have
30 seconds to find a banana.
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Anyone have a
banana?  Anyone?  Oh, awesome.
We got a banana over here.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: Thanks,
man.
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Here we
go.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: All
right.  Our high score is going
up.
Let's see what our next item is.
Beer.
(laughter).
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Beer?
Daniel it's 12:30 in the middle
of I/O, let's get back to the
talk man.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: All
right.  (Laughing).
>> NIKHIL THORAT: All
right.  So let's talk a little
bit about how we actually built
that game.  Let's switch back to
the slides here.  Okay.
So what we did was we trained a
model
in Python to predict from images
400 different classes that would
be good for an emoji scavenger
hunt game.  These are things
like a banana, watch, and  shoe.
The way we did this was we
took a pretrained model called
MobileNet and if you don't know
what MobileNet is, it's a state
of the art computer vision model
that's designed for Edge
devices, designed for mobile
phones.
So what we did is took that
model and we reused the features
that are learned there and we
either transfer learning task to
our 400 class classifier.
So then once we do that we have
an object detector, so this
object detector lives entirely
in the Python world, so the next
step of this process is to
actually take that and convert
it into a format that will be
able to ingest in the web and
then we'll skin the game and add
sound effects and that kind of
thing.
So let's talk a little bit
about the details of actually
going through that process.
So in Python when we're actually
checkpointing and train training
our model we have to train it to
disk.  There is a couple ways to
do this, the common way with
TensorFlow is to use what's
called a saved model.  Details
are not important for this talk
here, but the idea here is that
there are files on disk that you
need to write.
Daniel also mentioned that we
support importing from Keras,
that's a high-level library that
lives on top of TensorFlow and
that gives you a sort of higher
level API to use these things.
Details are unimportant but
there are also files on disk
that it uses to checkpoint.
All right, so we have a set of
files and now next up is to
actually convert them to a
format that we can ingest in a
web page.
So we have released a tool on
PIP called TensorFlow.js and
inside of that tool we have some
conversion scripts.  All you do
is run the script, you point it
to those saved files that you
had on disk, and you point it to
an output directory and you will
get a set of static build
artifacts that we'll be able to
use on the  web.
The same flow holds for Keras
models you point for the input H
file
and out pops a factory of static
build artifacts.  So you take
the static build artifacts and
host them on the website, the
same
way you host TFGs or anything of
that sort.
Once you do that we provide APIs
in TensorFlow.js to load the
static build artifacts, so it
looks something like this.
For TensorFlow Save Model we
load the model up and get an
object back.  That model object
can actually make predictions
with TensorFlow.js tensors right
in the  browser.
The same flow holds for Keras
models, we point to the static
build artifacts and we have a
model that we can make
predictions on.  Okay.  So under
the covers there is actually a
lot going on.  When we convert
these files to a format that we
can ingest in the web, we
actually are  pruning nodes off
of that
graph that aren't needed to make
that prediction, and this makes
the network transfer much
smaller and our predictions much
faster.
We're also taking those weights
and sharding and  packing them
into 4 megabyte chunks and that
means the next
time the browser loads the page
it will be cached so it's super
snappy.
We support also about 90 of
the most commonly used
TensorFlow ops today and are
working hard to continually
support more n on the Keras side
we
support 32 of the most commonly
used Keras layers during the
supporting phase and also
computing and training of the
models so computing accuracy
once you get them in, and of
course you can also make
predictions as well.
All right.  So I want to show
you a demo before I  bore you
anymore.
This demo is built by our
friends at  Creative Lab.  As a
collaboration between them and a
few researchers on Google Brand,
so I'm going to go back over
here to this laptop.
Okay, so the idea of this model
is it takes a 2D image of a
human being and it estimates a
set of keypoints that relate to
their skeleton, so things like
your wrist point, the centers of
your
eyes, your shoulders, and that
kind of thing.  So I'm just
going to turn a demo on here.
When I do that the webcam will
turn on and start predicting
some key points for me.  I'm
going to step back here so you
can actually see the full thing,
and as you move around you'll
see the skeleton
change and make some predictions
about me.
All right.  So there is
obviously a lot you can do with
this.  We were really excited to
show you a fun little demo.
It's very thin, and what's going
to happen is when I click this
slider we're going to move to a
separate mode where it's going
to look for another image on the
Internet that has a person with
the same pose as me.  Okay?
Let's try that.  Is it going to
work here?
Of course it's not working now.
Okay.  We have a physical
installation of this which you
can go check out at the
experiments tent on H and it's
really fun, it's a full screen
version of that where you can
see another version of you.
We have released this model on
NPM so you can use this and you
need no Machine Learning
experience to do it.  The API
lets you point to an image and
out pops an array of key points,
it's that easy, so we're really
excited to see what you do with
that.
Okay.  So there is a lot
that you can do with just
porting the models to the
browser for inference.  Since
the beginning of deeplearning.js
and TensorFlow.js we've made it
a high priority to actually
train directly in the  browser
and this opens up the door for
education,  interactivity as
well as retraining with data
that never leaves the client.
So I'm going to actually
show you another demo of that
back on the laptop over here.
Okay.  Daniel, do you want to
come help me?  Here we go.
Cool.
So the game is in three
phases.
In phase one we're going to
actually collect frames from the
webcam and what we're going to
do is use those frames to
actually play a game of Packman.
So Daniel, why don't you start
collecting frames and what he's
going to do is going to collect
frames to up, down, left, and
right, and those are going to be
associated with the poses with
the four controls for the
Packman game itself.
So as he's collecting those
we're saving some of the images
locally and we're not actually
training them all  yet.  So once
he's done actually collecting
those frames, we're going to
train the model and again, this
is going to be trained entirely
in the browser with no request
to a server anywhere.
Okay.  So when we actually
train that model, what's going
to happen is we're actually
going to take a  pre-trained
MobileNet model that's actually
in the page right now and we're
going to do a little retraining
phase with data that's he's just
collected.  So why don't you
press that train model.
Awesome.  Our loss value is
going down and it looks like
we've learned something.  Okay.
So the phase three of this game
is to actually play, and so when
he presses that button, what's
going to happen is we're going
to take  frames from that webcam
and we're going to make
predictions given that model
that we just trained.
Why don't you press that play
button and we'll see how it
goes.  If you look at the bottom
right of the screen we see the
predictions happening.  It's
highlighting the control that it
thinks it is and you'll see him
actually playing the Packman
game now.
So obviously this is just a
game, but we're really excited
about opportunities for
accessibility, you can imagine
the chrome extension that lets
you train a model that lets you
scroll the page and click.
Now all of this code is online
and available for you to go in
and build your own applications
with and we're really excited to
see what you do with it.  All
right, man, back to the talk.
>> DANIEL SMILKOV: All
right.
(Applause).
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Okay, so
let's chat a little bit about
performance.  What we're looking
at here is a  benchmark of
MobileNet 1.0 running with
TensorFlow Python, this is
classic TensorFlow, not running
with TensorFlow.js.  We're
thinking about this in the
context of a batch size of one
and the reason that we want to
think like that is because we're
thinking of an interactive
application like  Packman where
you can only read one sensor
frame at a time so you can't
really batch that data.
On the first reel we're
looking at
TensorFlow running with CUDA on
a 1080 GTX, a beefy machine and
3 milliseconds
per frame, and I want to mention
the smaller the bar the faster
it is.
The second row is
TensorFlow CPU
running with AVX2 instructions
on one of
these Mac Book Pro here.  We're
getting about 60 seconds a
frame.  Where does GTX fit in?
Well it depends.
So running on the 1080GTX, that
beefy machine, we're getting
about 11 milliseconds per frame.
On TensorFlow.
js running on integrated
graphics we're getting about 100
milliseconds per frame.  I want
to point out that 100
milliseconds is not so bad, that
Packman game was running with
this model and you can really
build something interactive with
that.
The web is only going to
get faster and faster.
There are a new set of standards
like
WebGL compute shaders and web
GPU that gives you much closer
access to the GPU, but the web
has its limitation, you live in
a sandbox environment and you
can only really get access to
the GPU through these APIs.  So
how do we scale beyond those
limitations?
With that I'm going to hand
it off to Nick who is going to
talk about how we'll scale.
>> NICK KREEGER: Thanks,
Nikhil.  Today we're launching
TensorFlow
support for Node.js.
(Applause).
We're really excited to
bring a easy to use high
performance machine
library to JavaScript
developers.  The Open Source
community around Node.js and NPM
is really awesome, there is
incredible movement in the
space, a ton
of libraries and packages for
developers to use today and now
we're bringing ML to this front.
The engine that runs Node.
js V8 is super fast, it's had
tons of resources put into it by
companies like Google, and we've
seen the interpreter
be up to 10 times as fast as
Python.  Lots of room for
performance improvements.
Also, using TensorFlow
gives us
access to really high end
Machine Learning hardware like
GPU devices and TPUs in the
Cloud.
Look for support for that soon.
Let's step back and look at
the architecture we highlighted
earlier.
We have a Layers API and at a
little
bit lower level Core API that
has our Ops.  This whole
runtime is powered by
WebGL in the browser, but today
through NPM we're shipping a
package that gives you
TensorFlow that gives you access
to those TPUs, the GPU and CPU.
All of this is through our MPM
package.
To show you how easy it is to
use
our Node bindings I want to show
you a code snippet.  This
application function right here
is a very common server side
request response handler for an
endpoint.  Those who have worked
with express framer know exactly
what's going on here.
Our endpoint listens for slash
model and takes input as a
request, which we pass into a
TensorFlow.js model and that
output is pushed out into the
response.
Now, to turn on high-performance
sensor flow code we only need
two lines of code, an import
that loads our binding, and then
an  existing API called the
setup back in the TensorFlow,
and now this model is running
with the performance of
TensorFlow.
Whether a works today out
of the box?  So we can take
pre-existing Python models and
run those natively in  Node.js.
The models we've kind of showed
off
today, all of those were run in
our Node runtime.  There is no
need to bring a Python stack to
your Node infrastructure, just
run it in JavaScript.
Our NPM package today ships a
off-the-shelf CPU  build, no
driver, just install the package
and you're up and running.
Our whole API that we ship
in TensorFlow.js will work with
our Node runtime.  Every API
that we've showcased will work
today out of the box.
Now, we've built a little demo
using Major League  Baseball
data in Node.js to show what can
you do with Machine Learning,
Node.js and JavaScript.
We've used Major  League
Baseball advanced media pitch
effects dataset to do some
Machine Learning.
The pitch effects dataset is a
large library of sensor data
about pitches that baseball
players have thrown in actual
baseball games.
For those that aren't super
familiar with baseball, we've
given a little context here.  A
pitcher will throw a different
type of pitch to fool the player
who is trying to hit this ball.
There is pitches that have
higher  velocities, pitches that
are a little slower but have
more movement, and in this
example we've sort of
highlighted the fast ball, the
changeup, and the curve ball,
those are all types of pitches
much don't get too hung up about
the details of baseball, but
what we're really trying to
solve here is a very classic
Machine Learning problem of
taking sensor information and
drawing a classification to
that.
So for that I'm going to
actually showcase this demo.
All right.
So on one side of my screen I
have a terminal that I'm going
to start my Node application
with, and on the left I have a
web browser.  We built this with
a very simple UI that listens to
what our server is doing over
sockets, and those who have used
the socket I/O library in  Node
know what this interaction is
doing.
I'm just going to type Node,
start my server, and now all
through Node my model is up and
running and training.  Every
time we take a pass through our
dataset we report that over the
socket to our client and can you
see the blue bar is moving a
little bit closer to 100%.
That's our model understanding
how to tell the difference
between a curveball
or fastball, and as you can kind
of see, every step it moves a
little bit differently.  And our
model is having a little bit of
trouble at the moment with the
fastball sinker but only looked
at data for a few passes.  The
more the server run the better
it gets at training.
So all of this training data
we've
shown is historical baseball
data from 2015 to 2017.  I'm
going to hit this test live
button
and this is going to use the
Node
framework to go out to Major
League baseball, pull in some
newer live data and run the
evaluation.
Once this data comes in, we're
going to see the orange bars,
and the orange bars show us how
much better we are at predicting
data that our model has never
seen  before.  These are live
pitches, and we're really good
at identifying the curveball
and not so create at that
fastball sinker still.
Let's jump back and continue to
look at our next slide.
This is the architecture of
what we were doing in that demo.
We've built a very simple Node
server that  hosts our
JavaScript models, and when we
hit that live button, it reaches
out to Major League Baseball,
pulls in the live data and runs
inference on the new pitches.
We continue to report that to
any connected clients through
the browser.
What is the stack up and
performance?  So in that
training set we were looking at
7,000 pitches and we were
training every couple seconds
7,000 pitches, so that's an
interesting benchmark but let's
actually classify
that with the MobileNet
benchmark we showcased earlier.
So these are the numbers for
Python TensorFlow, the  GPU and
CPU inference time.  We're just
getting started, we just
launched an MPM package, we have
a lot of ways to go, but we have
some promising early numbers to
showcase.
TensorFlow with Node.js is
exactly as past as Python
TensorFlow, and so with that I'm
going
to hand it off to Nikhil to wrap
up.
>> NIKHIL THORAT: Thanks, Nick.
Exciting stuff.
Okay, so let's recap some of the
APIs and libraries and tools
that we have supported today
with TensorFlow.js.  We have a
low-level API called the Core
API which is a set of
accelerated
linear algebra kernels and a
layer for automatic
differentiation, we saw an
example of with that with the
polynomial regression demo.
We also have a high-level Layers
API that encodes Machine
Learning best
practices into an API that's
much more easy to use, and we
saw an example of that with the
addition of RNN translation
demo.
We also have showed you a
couple of ways that you can take
pretrained models
from Python via saved model or
via Keras models and import to
the browser for inference or
doing retraining or computing
accuracy.
And of course, we also
showed you the new Node.js
support for TensorFlow.
js today, and we're really
excited about that.
Okay.  So this project,
TensorFlow.js was not just the
three of us on the stage here.
It was a cross-team
collaboration
between many amazing people at
Google, and we also have some
amazing Open Source contributors
that I want to send a shout out
to.  This project literally
would not have been possible
without them, so thank you.
All of the things that we
talked
about here today, the demos, all
of the
code is Open Sourced on our
website  js.tensorFlow.org and
all of the code is also Open
Sourced on
GitHub/TensorFlow/tfjs.  We also
have a community  mailing list,
a place where people can go and
ask  questions, post their demos
and that kind of thing.
We have some office hours today
at 3:30 and we have some office
hours
tomorrow at 9:30, which I invite
you to come and talk to us in
person, and we also have some
tents, we have the Experiments
Tent at H, that's where that
Move  Mirror Demo the full
screen version of that will be,
and we'll also be at the AI Tent
as well.
So we are really excited to
build the next chapter of
Machine Learning and JavaScript
with you.  Thank you.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits.